You
Oh my gosh, hi, I like just woke up from a nap
Let me just hold on I'm like really in the middle
Tee hee, how are you guys doing? Oh, I forgot I
I
Flipped myself. I need to flip myself off
No, they normally just bouncing around
You'll soon learn that my streams are just a constant wave of scuff. I don't
Know what to tell you
Okay, doesn't really matter that much I suppose
How are you guys doing today? I was um took a little nappy. I feel good. I have some lemon odd
Sipping on some lemon odd
I'm
Everything I do is perfect you will learn that is far from the truth my dear
But I know
People have some
qualms with my sound so let's
If you don't mind and you don't because I'm telling you you're gonna help me
with my sound
With my microphone right now. I look great today
Brother in Christ. I look the same. I'm like a I'm a cartoon character
This is this I wake up
I'm in the same outfit. I open my closet. It's constant Shabari ropes in office wear
Okay, so let's let's let me pull up my
Maya Feltas I had some in my Maros go like they
Gonna gave me a giggle
They're like wow you really offended me yesterday, and I'm like in my head like reading I'm like, oh
What did I do? Not that I give a shit, and it was like I can't believe you said, but oh whoa
Like that was the most terrible thing you could ever say to make fun of British people and it gave me a chuckle
How do we know you're not secretly an Android you don't I
Could be an Android you do not know, but why do I sound like um?
the robot from Power Rangers alpha
Okay, so I have a noise gate and I have a compressor and
I have some other filters here
But I feel like they tend to
Mess up my voice in terms of when I scream it
Kind of just blocks me out, so I took off the the noise suppression one
Bit cringe in you, bro. Oh
Wait, what what days it today? Oh fuck. It's Monday. Damn it. I can't do the bit
Do you pay on to be screaming a lot? I I was doing a lot of errands this morning because I lost my bank card because
your girls is is
as clumsy as fuck but um
Uh, so I was blasting
Just like scream music
Probably I was like, I probably shouldn't
Be singing right now so I can save my voice and I'm like fuck that
I was gonna belt my heart out and then you know as some of you saw I was listening to some
Dembo because I like a bit of Dembo to get me hype
I'm gonna put in the loop in the loop print print print print
Shout out to my Dominic comments. Um, how do we know you're not British? I actually I am English
I'm not from the UK, but I am English. I am English Scottish. I'm a Brazilian different things
You'll unlock those things with time
Let's make a river food
Lops no crab legs. I had lobster roll today though for lunch is a little treat. I'm like, you know what?
You deserve a little treat for debut. Let me go and get some a lobster roll and some
I got some clam chatter
We lost a good one lads
Lads your Brit you think talking like this I sound like a Brit
Oh white woman jumpscare. Oh
My god, she's why
Would you revive the queen if you could of course I would I the woman that woman
Practically raised me now. She didn't we knew we knew each other for a good amount of time
It was a good like
Like three or so years and we got super close in those years, but
Yeah, I'm still I'm still healing from those wounds
She is a she was a big part of my life
What color was the chowder?
White I don't it's it's fucking chowder. I don't
It was clam chowder
I was late. I'm sorry
Somebody flog him you can choose amongst yourselves who gets the privilege to beat that guy. So go ahead
Did you ever Dom Queen? I didn't Dom Queen so in my
early
Adolescence that's fucked
In our early time together. I was very submissive. I actually you can even say I keep these ropes on as
That homage to her, you know
She did teach me about doming, but I didn't dom her I
Did not dom her Lord dump
Um, it's crazy because I'm making this up for the spot. So I'm happy you guys are cool with that. I
Say we take turns at flogging. I agree with that not
Not the blind cane
Even with the blind cane
Okay, um, so yeah
as I was saying
So I'm gonna fiddle around with my settings real quick. So
You can hear my fan because I have a fan for my phone for when I stream
So it doesn't overheat and then naturally my computer has a fan
So you might be hearing the fans and you might also be hearing my AC. Can we jump them?
Of course, you can jump them. Wait, did your beauty mark switch size? No, I'm mirrored and I can't un-mirror myself
It like won't let me
Flip myself for some reason like I'm trying desperately to flip
my
thinking it won't let me flip
If I flip vertical oh
I know why it's because I had it locked aren't I a silly goober?
Hey
Now my moles on the right side
It's funny. I actually do have a mole on my tit except it's not in the center toward like like I do on my my
virtual self it's on the
Towards the outside like right where I don't know
There's any ladies in the chat
Rare um right where you're like your bra strap would go to I don't know everybody's boobs are different never mind
Why am I describing this?
Lord drop I have yeah, I have a lot of beauty marks. I've won on my armpit. I have one on my titty. I have one on my
Just like on my arm in general my tummy. I
Have a lot of freckles. I'm just looking at myself now. I'm just wearing a t-shirt. So
Wearing a t-shirt
some pants on us and out just hit my head on my microphone and
Some pushing slippers cuz I always keep it real
Freckles girl plug. Yeah, I have a beauty. I have beauty marks on my face as well
You'll never see
I don't know. I'm describing if you'll never see
Where is
Hold on. Let me do it. I'm too close to you. I'm so sorry step back you're dancing kind of close
On you
Can we just look at my thighs for a second like sometimes I'll just go on
Put on live 2d and just stare at my own legs cuz goddamn like I was never really a tights gal
But I'd like my legs, you know, I would just add some supple thighs
Okay, anyway, sorry I'm getting distracted
Ah
4k are these the she be zoomies the other way did they say I have zoomies
Did they say I have zoomies crap
The roadbook is exquisite. I actually
Guys guys, I'm gonna I'm gonna can I just hold on let me get closer
Can I tell you a secret how I just hit my face on the microphone? Can I tell you a secret?
Come here. Come here. Come here lane real real close. We're close. Okay. I
Don't know how to tie Shabari
So we're gonna do some membership streams where I learn how to tie myself up
Pog okay, I
Thought she was gonna purr. I'm not gonna just do that. I
Haven't had anything yesterday
I had had seltzer water and when I also get super anxious and I also had something that upsets my tummy
So I was burping a lot, but you know, it's a normal bodily function. So I'm sorry. I'm not gonna mute
Myself if I burp one I I don't have the speed to do so
I remember one time I went to mute for a two and I totally didn't make it in time
People were like, what was that? And I was like, wow my cat just
Totally ripped ass next to me. That was wild. Oh, wow
whoa
Wowie Zowie
What were we doing again? Oh, yeah, we were helping my microphone issues
Okay, so if I do the open threshold if I do this
Well
Well, I
Don't know does that make a difference does that make a difference? Oh
Excuse me. Oh, wow
See, I'm I supposed to it's an unconscious thing to do
Not much of a difference at all. Okay, cuz that was my open threshold. So I'm just gonna ooh
What about my clothes threshold? What if I?
Hey mama hey
Hey
Does that make a difference? I don't freaking know
Four out of ten, sorry, you know what I'll take them as I take them
My air conditioning is about to get gone. This will be helpful. Um
So my clothes threshold is that you can't tell. Oh my god, okay
I'll just put these but they were before so it could be my compressor
so
What if I
What if I do this
Isn't working so this is me with nothing on
And not in terms of clothes though that would be pretty crazy for YouTube
She be cotton bun ripped off her clothes on her third stream
I still hear the AC. Well, I just took off the filters. That's why
Your sound's going all over the place because yeah, I just it was better for a moment
Huh picture can't hear me
Fuck something
What about now super quiet super quiet can't hear oh that was the current compressor
Hold on
Let me just I'll put it back to what it was. It's like there
Fuck what did I have this on shit fuck? Oh, no, wait, I think I took a picture on my phone
Let me just stare at you intensely for a second because I have my settings. Nope, that's not it
Chat is this real? That was three to one. Okay
I
Got a
Blood trail red in the blue. Hey, you know, I'm thankful for having AC because then there's Emmy who doesn't have a seat
She just dies all the time and I feel so bad
Um
Sorry drinking she's looking at what I do just play cool bro. Oh my god, she's talking to me
play cool
The more I stream the more on there. It's only it's only my third day out here
I'm like, oh, there's a bully delinquent outfit or I just like bully you'd be so cool
younger younger she be
Like I did the other day like oh my god, don't you have any friends?
So you like watch like cartoons and stuff, right?
like
Like you watch like a hold on. Let me and you get my my valley my valley girl accent in there
so you like watch like
On the movie what's it called?
Neruto
That's really weird. I
Was watching digrassy. I can't think of a normal show
So like did you draw that oh
My god, you're such a good. Can you draw me?
You're such a good artist
You can't draw me. What do you mean? You can't draw me
Gossip girls. Oh, I fucking love gossip girl
Me and the girls have a joke. I'm about to expose this right now where um
when we
Have to use the bathroom. There's like this meme. That's like it's Blair going go piss girl and we just say go piss girl
Let me like oh, sorry. Hold on like we're like playing a game
We're like in a meeting like I got to go pee and we're like go piss girl
I
Bring back memories of female bullies a some are all play
She be bullies you is your childhood bully
so like
Do you have a crush on anybody? Oh?
My god, do you have a crush on Stacy Milker 10? I
Won't no, no, I won't tell her I won't tell you know what you should do
She really likes animu. Yeah, you should tell her about it
Not Milker 10
Yeah, my uh, I who was it? No, I was always she be but
Imagine my name was shy be
What what would my mean girl name be? What would be my alter ego mean girl name?
Cuz like cotton bottom whatever
I'm not gonna be shibbety toilet. So shut your mouth right now. I have to burp
Excuse me
Sabimbo what?
When oh, I like when although I do also like spider-man into the spider-man
Fondle it no not font that's so
Fondle and Stacy Milker 10 are Azura's elder elder egos the tiffster
Shelby cotton grass
Chabelle oh, I think Chabelle is good
Chabelle cotton grass
Cotton ass
Vanessa I've been told that I look like a Vanessa and I don't know what that means
As someone who lives in California, I can assure that 90% of the girls here sound like Valley girls
Like but even the guys have the accent too. Like I had a teacher. I remember
growing up he was the
Sock like the girl soccer coach or something and he I think he can't yeah, he like came from California
and he's also my physics teacher and
He was like alright guys today. Like I can't even do it as a like as a guy, but it was just really
weird
Cuz I'm like is he you know I
I
Can't wink um, but he wasn't this is how I talk
Shibriela Shabbath
Bethany and like all like the California
Hey, what's up guys? I'm about to ride some waves after driving down whichever and go into LAX
Shibuya
Shibriela, that sounds like my my DJ name like Spinderella, you know
Shibritney
Shabeki Shabrata. No, that's not a mean girl name
ship
That looked like a different word. I'm not saying that
Shabro. Oh my god, I should have called you guys my shabronis
I'm just a jabronis. You guys are my shabronis
But and then that your little play on the people thinking I'm a horse in my my concept art
Shigamarth that just sounds like a Cthulhu outer worlds being
Shibri-ish Shakeel. Yo, what's up? I'm Shakeel
Shabronis um
So, yeah, you guys they're my oh guys are my harem
Okay, you know what fuck the
Wait, does this make a difference
What if I I
Like so I
Really like divisibles of five because I have OCD so I have to put this on like a number so I'm fixing my stuff
Does that sound fine? You're not hearing it. Well, the AC just turned off. So that's why you're not hearing it
I never had this issue during the winter
Because I didn't actually know my heat would kick on
Do you have a low pass soldier? I don't know what that means
Shalizabeth Cottenson. Oh, I like Cottenson. Okay, so I'm I
Like Shabelle
Or Shabethany
Hold on Shabethany was really good
Shabelle Cottenson or Shabethany
This is the crab dark. Shut up. We're gonna get there be quiet. Oh, it's because it put my up put game down
Well boner
Shabelle, that's isn't that like a goat
Shabethany, okay, so Shabethany
Shashill what see still cotton ham. That's my my British alter ego
Hi, how about Shabelle cotton son is
My British version and then Shabethany is my mean girl version
Shabelle the band
Uh
Shabritney cotton boy Shabethany
Shabella
Shabethany mistress above all you're not if I'm if I'm like a high school delinquent
You're not gonna call me mistress because that would just be almost like make you do that
Mistress the Bethany Shabbethany. What's my jersey name?
like uh like the
joysy shore
Into the she beaver Shakira
Wait, I wanted to do so how long have I been I've been streaming for to see I told you I
Told you this would happen
I'll talk for 30 minutes and not stream. I
am known for
Mapping like the first hour and then streaming for maybe an hour or two afterwards the actual game, so
Sorry
Hold on. I wanted to show you guys a picture of you because I didn't show it
I also didn't show my merch, but I'll do that whatever later
My merch looks fucking sick though
Check out the description below and check out my merch on whoo market
It's all like Cody
Image
Let's see if I can find it
Somebody give me a song to sing while I look for this
I'm gonna singy mood
We're getting done
YMCA young man
There's no need to be down. I said young man
Don't know the lyric afterwards young man
Something something something
It's fun to say the YMCA
Oh, I need to type it's I can't type and take it the same time
mascot
Why am CAA? Oh?
Can I download this?
Cool, it's fucking good, mate
Holy guacamole you guys are huge
All right, harem oh
Crap
No, I looked at the viewer count
as I opened the tab
We were count jump scare
So that's you you look so again as
People may not know I didn't hot I did not design the mascot. I did not design she be I was hired on to play
Myself although I am who I am I was meant to be I was meant to be she be my entire life
You know then week before I or
Yeah, like the week before I
Streamed like I did debut I saw rabbits every day outside my apartment never before I'm like the universe is telling me
I'm meant to be a bunny girl, or I meant to be a playboy bunny which one um
But I the moment I saw this I was like this looks like like tuxedo mask or a persona character
And I like it a lot. I think it's cute
Use of the harem and you know what I was like I'm like, oh
You can change your hat
You can change the type of ropes you're wearing if you don't want to have a scarf on because I also like I
Know I do have female viewers you can feminize this you can do like a more feminine mask or like a
More feminine hat, so I just I want you to be able to you know
Mix and match, but that's that's you got you guys look a little mafia bosses. It's a rabbit Junkler for
I
Can't think about persona five. I've actually never played persona five don't come at me
so
But I was trying to think of like some sort of goofy little thing
She'd be representing the 3% female audience so out of curiosity
I was looking to like edit like a description one of the videos because I had like done a typo and
What I
Accidentally ended up doing was seeing the demographic for
Um
Who watches my content and it was 99% men and
1% women so shout out to those ladies out there
This is for the girlies
Hair Sona, ooh hair my Sona my hair Sona
One percent is one percent shout out to the five girls in chat. You just know you're loved
You women
Don't say that
You two was just even massive sausage party, you know, it's weird. I don't like I feel like it would be the opposite
Like I'm sorry. I thought you the bros it all be on like reddit or
lively
Lady kumar, but I'm not full kumar all the time am I kumar right now?
No, we're talking. We're having a good time. Yes
My titties are massive and I'm wearing bondage clothing and I have a ball gag as a choker
But that's besides the point. This is girl talk. Okay. This is she be talk
You were a few hours ago. I was what?
That was dumb probably I
Think is dead. I don't know. I haven't been on that site
Live leak would be someone's live tag. Oh, it's as a leak is
Is Azura's NSFW
Hashtag you can't see I'm doing a hashtag with my fingers hashtag
So basically we need second she be outfit to learn more female viewers I
think
strongy and management is like worried about
Applying for monetization because like we definitely have it already
for me and Azura because we get we like ran ads on our shorts just to like to test stuff out and
YouTube took a cent from us, but didn't run the ads
Because of the boobs in the thumbnail bitch because of boobs in the thumbnail bitch
And she be up. Oh, oh
That'd be funny
That would actually be kind of funny like a tomboy outfit. I think I'd like to I'm pretty sure that I
Am I the most tomboyish besides straw knee out of everything? I don't know my kid my my demeanor
But more of the bros, you know
Wow, she'd be such a pick me
There is a smudge on my screen. It's making me look like I have a mole on my face and I look kind of hot with it
So I'm like, hmm
More on my face
Tom-dom ha ha
Bealer shirts aren't everything. I don't cut like so. Yeah, I might have like a thing where my shirts closed
And I'm
It's like I just don't know for the life of them. I just I can't do it right now. I haven't heard her today
I just can't for the life of me
Fathom why they wouldn't run ads and they took a cent and I'm like mom
Momay, they I have a ball gag the only time I can be advertiser friendly if it's if I'm like this
Oh shit, I'm close. Oh, hey, that's finally work. You took me three hours to set up the stupid thing yesterday
Let's see, I'm gonna look over right there
So it looks like I'm saying your names above my head
I'm not that see I'm not I was in chorus when I was younger and we had to
Sing what's it called? Um, we did a lot of Disney songs. So I know a lot of Disney songs
And we did under the sea in kiss to go
Yeah, you see her sitting here across the way
She don't got a lot to say but there's something about
Oh, I can hear myself what the hell gross oh
Jesus Christ jumpscare
Under the sheebie, okay, where did my I have to plug in my DualSense controller
Oh my god, this is my favorite Titanic song. Oh, are you ready kids?
I can't hear you
It's probably not scream
The sound of the AC is the sound of the waves exactly you get it
Hold on that's gonna so bother me that you guys can hear it though
Didi didi didi didi didi didi didi didi
Is that better it's gonna suppress me in it and I'll I'll get cut out but
It's better, okay I
Just threw a noise suppression on but if I screw
It's not gonna it's not gonna be fun
Just so you know
Just so you know I'm gonna cut out
What why are you laughing
Did it did it get like crunchy in the end? Yes, it suppressed as you said
Can you try whispering
You can't hear me scream the cutout screams. I don't think this is a horror game
How about whimpering
Did it pick out up this first cutout oh look
Suppression level all right suppression level. What is that?
How about this how about this?
Wow, how would you be streamed today? Oh, but it was great
We just sat for 30 minutes and she talked about nothing and we distilled didn't help her fix her microphone
Okay, but if I
Did it cut me off though did it cut me off
You can still hear me. Are you sure are you positive? No, you hear it. No
What the screams are fine. No. Yes. No, you guys are not helpful
No, no cutting off. Oh no cutting off
Okay, whatever the fuck. It's cool. We ball
The mic peaked. Okay, cool
But it's funny cuz my air conditioning shut off, so we'll never know if it actually worked. Okay
Anyways
This is working. I haven't charged this controller in a bit
What word comes to mind when you think of the earth fucking sucks that word might be beautiful
No dog
or
unstable or full of shit
Hey, it's my word of the year I like to pick a word of the year
But I focus on it's resilient this year
Hey, it was Johnny, we know those octopus so was a cousin
Where the sea turtle vtubers at
Where the crab vtubers at put your claws up
Can I get a ooo Connie in the chat? Oh
Well, that's not a sea turtle. He's just a turtle
I
Don't need this by the way. Oh, it's last year's word. It was um, I think it was patience after a member. What the hell
Please open up. Oh, I'm so cute
Oh
This is so adorable. Hello
Slacktide
They close this
Oh crap the tack shark he's called a lone shark and he sounds like he's like Italian mafia. That's funny as hell
What are taxes me
This whole area
Commit tax evasion now I have to like get an accountant now. What's a V sucky? You don't need to know
So the lore is
I evaded taxes
You're somewhere
I oh
Oh
On da da sea oh, there's a freaking bird there. Oh my god. I'm scared
Game is quiet. Can you turn it up? Is it? I have it pretty high
Oh
Wow was randomly super quiet. I don't know why
All right
Quick poster on oh shit, you're right
I keep forgetting guys. I'm not
I'm not used to being a streamer. No, that's that's a fucking lie. I'm not used to
Like streaming on youtube has because I used to be a twitch streamer streaming on youtube is very
Very confusing and very annoying to set up
But it's the easiest thing to do in terms from v2 management. That's why there's a lot of v2 corpos on um
agencies on
YouTube because you can manage
No, I don't want to upgrade to premium. You can manage multiple accounts and payouts and all that jazz
Can I please tweet?
I
Manager tweet for me
Uh
There it is
The temptation to speak like live from new york is saturday night
I'm live link in thread
I've been streaming for
40 minutes
And forgot for gore to tweet again
I forget to do a lot of things I forget I forget to do a lot of things twitch sucks
Ah
Twitch sucks. I know um, sorry I sing a lot
But I'm not a good singer
Uh, it's okay. I think just because I I'm it's what I'm used to okay. So heart kelp
heart kelp is
Is currency but also health question mark
Hey, I know this isn't much but
What the shell is it wait, I don't forget what he sounded like
What that shell is this or he sounded like he was from joysie
They're help kelp heart kelp pods
Don't tell me you don't even like heart kelp
I hope you're joking no one uses these dub things as money anymore
The oceans moved as the trash stand and now trash you got it
Trash so like no pearls either no shiny pirate coins
That's right. None of that crap
So you better find some bread clips or some sauce packets back there. I'm losing my darn patience
Look if if you just give me a couple more tides
All right. I've had enough say. Goodbye to your shallow idiot
Wait, what?
Oh crab
I'm naked
Oh crap. Oh crap crap crap
Oh
Not my booty hole not my crab bussy being out
Not my crab bussy is my music too loud by the way
She'd be the tax collector ASMR
Hello, hello people just coming in because they're like oh she did oh come here, bitch
Holds serve a sprint. Hey
I just want to know
How's a shark is there like a shark?
It's tide pools
Who's controlling the shark?
Because this are cut off. How does he how?
Am I supposed to be going faster is this timed?
Oh, I'm okay cool
I need to burp
You do the Naruto run. I used to call that growing up. We used to call it running ninja style
And I'll tell you
Running ninja style is very effective
Uh, I was one of the fastest girls in middle school. I'll have you know because I ran
ninja style
You're playing tag. I'm gone. I'm jumping through the trees. I'm like, what's up? Konoha, you know
Oh, no, you're one of I was I was I was yeah
Shout out to my warrior cats girlies as well by the way
Uh
I was uh
Night, I forget what the frick my name was night run the medicine cat or something
She be run, don't you too?
She be asked to be paid for your taxes
Not my problem. You want your shell back. You better get a job to pay up. I hear they're always hiring in the reef
Uh reef, isn't it super busy there? I don't want to talk to people
Again, not my problem. I don't care where you get the trash from but I'm keeping this until you do
See you later
smell you later
Krabby
whole
Crap crap crap crap crap crap
Shake dat ding. Yes. No, no, no shake dat ting. Can I jump? Okay. Okay
We got oh, oh, oh, oh we got dodge roll. Mm-hmm
We got nothing else. Okay
I
Do the crab shaking
All I want to do is I'm a zoom zoom zoom and a boom boom. Just shake your shell
Check baby check baby one two three. This is really pretty. This is a pretty game. I'm surprised my computer can run it. Oh
Oh, okay, so I like I glide
Well, I fucked that up. Okay
Nope, uh another thing you'll learn about me is I suck at platformers
Blight town or whatever the fuck it's called from um
From lives of
I keep I'm so used to lives of pee. I'm like pressing my joystick to run but that's not the case
Okay, all right
Wait, can I
Oh frick yeah, okay
Oh, that's not what I meant to do. How do I pick up?
breadclaw
it's
It's one of those things you used to cook trip to fucking bread with he
Acknowledge knowledge. That's cute
Church section. Blight town be tasty. Blight town is dark souls. Oh, I know I remember
Some people who've watched me before
It took me like six hours to beat that stupid
clown looking
Mini boss like it wasn't even a major boss mind you like the hardest boss in lives of pee. I beat no problem
like maybe like three tries but then
The fucking mini clown boss one where he like pushes a boulder at you
I
I had to I got mad. I raged. I closed my stream off
And then I had to um, oh, who's that? Let me just stand over here. He's probably an enemy
And then I had to
I was like, you know, fuck it. I'll beat it offline because I'm getting too frustrated. I don't think it's fun to watch someone rage too hard
um
and
I'm playing
Playing an hour passes. I still haven't beat him. I get so pissed. I spike my
I'm wearing razor black shark headphones. I spike them and they just shatter
So I have little chunks taken out of my headphones where the plastic is
Beat it off line versus beat it beat it off live versus beat it offline
for a rage to whining
The mother of a clown man. I feel it. What?
Tree get woke. Yeah, you know, I got my moments
Oh
Oh, yeah, I'm like spiked
Keyboards I've I pulled some Tyler ones. I've spiked. Uh, what's it called?
Um controllers
I like I remember I smashed my xbox controller at one point everyone was playing them
Work work work work work. That's what I'm trying to not do. That's why I got to catch up with
worthless
Holy crap. What's wrong with your eyes? I haven't been sleeping or oh god get the way for me
I'm not gonna fight you. Oh, there's so fucking many of them
Oh
Climb climb ha ha you bitches can't climb can you you?
Oh wait, you kind of can uh, no, you're just big
All right, I hope I don't miss anything back there if I did
She's a rager. It's funny. I used to not be rager until I started playing souls like games
But I like the rage from a souls like game. Although, you know, I would rage when I played like cotton stuff
Or like counter strike. Oh, I was so toxic when I played counter strike
I was bad
I was one of those bitches in the lobby that would try to talk like a little boy
So people wouldn't be like is that a girl? Huh going to kitchen
Ooh
Is this my weapon?
I guess I couldn't hurt to have a way to defend myself
This thing's here. I can't talk
If anyone else attacks me, I guess I'll poke him with the pokey bit
Might as well give this bad boy a few practice swings
Found a rusty fork
That suspiciously sounds like the call of the lamb
Thing when you
Like upgrade something attack charge attack
Oh, okay
And this is block. I wonder if I can parry
Please rage on us if you insist. I stopped playing multi games because I raged so much I wasn't able to sleep
Black ops 6 looks actually good. Yeah me and strawnee and a zero are like do we cop? Do we cop and we play?
Because like come on imagine me and azura and strawnee playing
That that'd be funny as fuck
How do I
Can I
Uh, I don't maybe I loop around
R3 to focus on enemies
All right
No, I'm pressing the wrong thing. Oh
Uh now how do I heal? Okay
Sounds like content
Going for fours of six and ever I play like a little bit of fours of an xbox grown up
I
Boy at hands if you play this kind of games or all the same level of skill in your line for a lot of fun. I
Used to I remember I got like
one of my
I play a lot of uh the
Battle royale, whatever the Frick version. Um
Of like the latest caught or like
Whatever and
I got like a golden
Gale like two days because there's no life to fuck out of it
I keep pressing trigger instead of r1
She may congratulate debut
Hold on
Hello sweet rain
Hope you're doing well
You may plus love
Warzone yes, thank you. Uh, yeah, I know life's warzone
I used to play fortnight, but I was just shit at building like my my my baby cousins. They're like, um
14 and 10 now they
smoke me in fortnight
And it's hilarious
Like like this like little 10 year old boy
Like I'm like, is there I'm telling my aunt. I'm like, can you put these kids like one of those like esport colleges?
Like this is ridiculous
I remember when I first started streaming in general. I used to be a fleshy. Um, I wanted to go pro and
Counter strike real bad
Because I was like, oh, I'd be sick to be like a female pro counter strike player
But I was not good enough
That's for sure. What is this? Can I hit it? Why is this pretty sick looking?
All right, no explanation for that. That's cool. Nice
Yeah, I know like they're like I'm doing 90s. Um, blah, blah, blah
I liked I played a lot of fortnight when it first came out and people didn't get the meta yet
About how building is super freaking helpful and they would just build
Pathetically, no, it's great. I miss those days
Whoa, what is that thing?
The current starts getting warm close to this platform. It's kind of comfy. I like I'm skipping every other word
Maybe I caress my feet here. He isn't
So you have feet
for a little while
Where are oh he has like
feet and then he has
Excuse me
He has a little feet that I guess he just doesn't use and then he has
Like one of them is like more raised. What's what's up with that?
Is that one like higher than this one? And then I have my little booty tail that
Hermit crabs used to like hold onto their shell. How many
Legs do crabs have? I don't know. I eat them, but I don't know
Oh
Oh moonshow
Nice out of 10 don't summon the feet bros
Cave of respite, I like the damn this game is so beautifully like it's just so aesthetically pleasing to me
Poppers and moonshows and my classic
Okay
Alrighty
Give me that. Well, do I have enough? Oh, I need okay. Oh
MSG hands, this is the damage of umami based attacks. Oh
Oh, yeah, so I don't have stuff yet. Okay. I thought I could just confirm to exit as well, but that's not the case
Is anybody am I gonna get like a explanation for like the lore of the moonshell?
No, all right
I don't know where I came from. You'll also learn that what the fuck is that?
Oh, it's him. I don't know why it looked like a bird to me. Um
And I'm I have a terrible sense of direction. I get turned around a lot
Too many legs six spiders in the sea
I
There's a dark souls mode and the options
I don't know that
You're lying. You gotta be lying
shibuti
As mommy based attacks
Go clean your room. I can't believe you got a b on your homework instead of an a
Mommy face attacks are perfect for Zara
Uh, I want to watch a Zara game. She's a great gamer. She kicked everybody's asses in uh among us
although
I kicked ass
in
Quiplash like one time I forget who won the most was a mercy that one more or was there Zara again
Who's the funniest?
Come on, man, there's gotta be something I can do
Yeah, now that you mentioned it, I can think of something drop your pants. Just kidding. You're not weighing any pants
You can lick my freaking ventral fins and stop bothering me
Lay the kid you can suck my two-headed cock
Well, this guy
sir's cracked
I was like so I watched everybody's two point os
And I just love listening to his airs voice and I was falling asleep listening to mercy because mercy also suits me
The fuck is this music
Ayo, is that my mouth? Oh, it's my heart inside my chest
Huh, it's very interesting that that's there. That's the asset
Whoa, whoa, whoa, don't say your type leaving the type pool too often
Yeah, well, I didn't have a choice. Can you tell me what's going on here?
I heard like there's a duchess in charge now
Yep, sure is real piece of work takes all my hard-earned micro plastics every tie just for existing around here
What do I see for it? Nothing just keeps building up her castle and hiring more soldiers to defend it
Oh, that's cool. Where can I find her? I think she has something in mind
So that's when I thought you're getting brand new models the day after debut
Why?
Why would you think that?
That's not gonna happen
Mommy put so much time and offered her money into these models. Oh my god. You guys don't even know the half of it
Kind of freeloader area, but you think you skirt your taxes while the rest of us keeps the side together, do you?
You just said
You hermit crabs are all the same wearing the shells the rest of us worked so hard to create with our own mantles
That's a good point. You gotta stayed in your tide pool small fry
Yeah, well how's about something I do something to you
Oh, oh shit, what the
Oh
Oh, I just fucking killed that guy, holy
Siegel breeze season
Okay
Killed him forked him fork you
You tell me I can't wear that on my butt
I could totally fit that on my ass
Like I know my ass is fat, but like I could totally slide that I can totally like, you know
Stretch them out stretch you out
Oh god, um
Where's a there's a chocolate
Oh, no, fuck you. I don't want to talk to you right now. Can you come up here? Oh, you can't
Okay, um
Wait, is that like a lure can I like there's plenty of plastics here. There's plenty of trash. Can I grab this?
I'll make my own micro plastics. Oh, this is really sad though
It was probably what the ocean. Oh looks like
I know I should be focusing on them, but I don't really care what that
Oh sick
Off to see the wizard
I'm wondering if there's anything off to the side. What's that?
Is that a shell?
Oh
No, it's just some weird party popper shit
Damn, this isn't big. Can I like go off the beaten track because I'm guessing that little
Little road the little micro plastic brick road is a um
It's like the main quest, but
I gotta what is this called
a
Bicolas sort of a big lighter
Have a fun so far. Uh, I just started
I was talking for too long
All right. Oh, who are you?
Are you like tree sentinel? Oh, yeah, you are. Oh, yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. No, thank you
Oh
Okay, oh
Fucking get it. Oh
Oh shit, I should probably run
What the
They're just doing absolute bangers
Yo, I need to get up and twerk. What is this?
Oh, oh, I went away. Fuck. I was about to get up. That's our cheek in my ass
Oh
Anyways
This game is cooler than I expected
I've seen like a little bit of gameplay from this
No, like spoiler. Oh, can I stick my mouth on that?
They're shiny so it means I can interact with them, right?
Just like uh from my spongebob. Oh, what's up there?
Oh
I should be able to platform up there. I just don't know how
If I
Maybe if I we're running start
Nope because I'm like, okay. What if I get up there
And then jump over there, but I don't think so. Fuck your mother. Fuck your mother. Fuck your mother. Fuck your mother
Oh
Why did the crab cross the road?
Can I
Is
Why is this fucking suspended and not floating? That's funny. Oh, that's fucking good. I got me
Uh, hello gentlemen, don't mind me. I'm just gonna
Oh
Spherulin my blood star easily
Okay
They won't notice me
Oh, I like how it kind of shimmies side to side like a crab
Can I am I dead? Oh shit
Well
Big matey cloche
FF. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Okay. I feel like I'm too hold on
I
Just fall through the map for a second
Put that up there, you know, I need to put these bitties on display, you know
For the end it doesn't even matter. We're uh, we'll be just started
We've gotten so wait. We're the no
Oh
Do I need to go yeah, I need to fucking oh
Anyways, I started blasting. Oh fuck, you know what I don't have time for this you can escape with your life
Do
First rule oh
Frick I'm not paying attention
Of dark souls that I learned the hard way is that you don't have to fight everyone again
I would go through and I would just try to fight people
And I'm like, oh wait
I can just run past you and come back to this later if I really need to talk to you or do this
thingy
What did you say?
We
What pow I got that boom boom bow the shallows
Is the shell gone? All right
Telling you music is good
I'm assuming I drop stuff. I think they did say that
Yeah, it's over there. I don't know why I press that but go off says
Are you winning? Oh
uh debatable
Wait, there's another thing. Oh, I'll look at that later
Okay, I don't need uh, okay fine come on come on
Wait, did you just shoot something from your mouth?
Come here
Why are you down there? Come on
I don't have to take on both of you at the same time. It's too much work
Do you have more? Oh, I wasn't locked on. Oh, I didn't even mean to
Oh, how did you brother excuse me
Don't don't don't
Check out laughs. Have you beat dark souls one play about that? No
The only game I've beaten is Elden Ring
I remember I played Sekiro and I'm like wow. Sekiro was the first um
Souls like I played I didn't even know it was a souls like I just was like, oh this game is getting a lot of hype
Let me get it and I
I
Was severely mistaken
What the fuck?
Are you why are you flying away? Oh god
Just fuck off already. Okay
Why can't I pick it up? I'm clicking try
Is this a joke? Oh wait, it's because
I
Mentioned I'm blonde
She be shut up
How can you
Oh fuck
I
Why do they cry like a puppy? Uh, I think I'm good. I don't know what that is. Is it a bird claw?
Is this the right way? I feel like it's barp talk ramping along distance
Oh, okay, cool beans. I think I keep going this way
Gotta go to the bonfire over here
You know blonde emo well, there is an emo of me going do so
I still don't think I have enough micro plastics or whatever the fuck to upgrade
Yeah
All right
Hey brother
Oh
That's all give me your fucking money
Oh, there's two in nature. Let's get that's my emmy impression
Just kidding. No, I actually I think if I'd really tried I want to do a stream where I try to do impressions of the girls
I
Think I could do icy's voice. I think I could do emmy's voice
I can't do strongy's voice because I can't get her accent down. I can kind of do Azura's voice
But
Mercy mercy is actually also kind of hard to do I really think about it
I realize if a girl's voice is like higher pitched. I can usually do it easier
I'm just going crazy and
Just talking to myself back ruffians back. I say
You there. I don't suppose you lend a claw to a fellow in need
I dare say I'd die for sure if you don't
Doesn't respond
um
Yeah, I'll kill them. Okay
I need them to come at me one at a time
Who's is don't fucking run away one of you guys come at me
Please
Oh
Is there no limited amount of times I can do that? Okay. No, there isn't it seems like I don't have like some sort of stamina, which is nice
Oh, you can dodge sweetie. Oh, so can I oh, oh you think you're so cool mean well you are
Oh fuck your mother
Oh
Why can you dodge stop it
Fine swordsmanship my boy. I dare say these ruffians ruffians
Not tomorrow today
These ruffians have become bolder and bolder as of late. Well, that's just life on the frontier. How exciting
Why not move away if it's so dangerous
Can't get off this prime land the justice offered me no way moray
Everybody bow thousand chat
Hit him with the do in here, mom
The duchess gave you land isn't there land all over the place
Ah the simple insights of country folk this really is the life
You deserve something for saving my carapace's country boy. Surely this could be of use. Good luck with your country travels
Sure
Get that thing over there. Oh jump scare
Hope I can like level this thing up or I wonder what other sort of weapons I can get
Oh, you see that broke the game. Let's get I know I did it
Okay, let's go back to where we oh there's one right next to me. I didn't even notice that
Oh might as well because it's here
Barking bark bark for me. I want you to bark for me right now like a dog. You are
Be a good puppy and bark woof woof
All right, this isn't bad too far can't wait to get my shit pushed in later
Oh god
Like now when I said later. I'm in now
Not tomorrow now. Oh fuck me. Fuck me. Fuck me. Oh
Oh
Where are you and I'm so sorry. I just got gang banged in my house tonight
Meow someone someone someone flog him
He didn't get the memo. Oh shit
Uh my stuff is is that I'm looking at the like map. Was there a map?
Oh
Well, what did you look at that is that that no why do this it's block
Scratch my head compass. Yeah, okay, so it was my stuff over there
Like the cute little compass
Oh
Where is it
No, I like how they like growl a little bit
Oh, you're telling me I can't jump up here
At least I can kind of like swim past them
Doobie doobie dooba
I I do wish I had some sort of
Like
Actually, no, I'm not gonna say that because I actually loved Elden Ring because of how open world it was
I feel like I'm close. I'm just gonna go around
Can I like
Plastic I can't I cut fuck you stop pumping my backside Jesus
Either ninja run or Ed's run
Me money. Yeah, no stamina bar is a good thing. What is that?
Hello
Why you got a fucking comb he's about to give me he's about to get the capsis the fade
Oh did not dodge in time
What the fuck was that? I'm like I'm crying. I just noticed I'm crab crawling
Oh, oh shit, okay, that's a two hit kill. That's good to know
Oh
Did I slice the glass bottle in half? Well, yes, I did. All right, uh, at least I know that I go this way
Oh, oh, okay, this must be the duchy
Okay, so let me just oh god a moment. I need to go get my stuff
So, yeah, this is like the path that I'm supposed to take of cigarette butts loveliness
I've asked you
Oh
Nope not this way oh for the love of god, where am I?
I want you to squeeze me while I'm on my period and call me your little catch-up packet
Call me your little fruit gusher. What a yo
Huh um base
Gushy-ushy someone sent in my marrow something
They said shabussy
And it gave me a good laugh, so thank you really I'm sorry for what I'm about to say and then they just said shabussy
What okay, what was that like in the wall?
Should I fight him should I fight him guys
My hands are sweating. Let me just wipe a mama titties
Shabby woody, I don't know what I'm talking about half the time do it for the plastic kill. Okay
We'll creep up
Oh
Shit, uh
I'm stuck. Oh god. What the fuck?
He needed me
He
Slam me against a wall. Okay. Yeah, I don't think I'm gonna fight him right now. I'm just gonna try to progress
It's kind of like the thing like you know you got to pick and choose your battles. It's okay
I don't
Like I definitely could beat him, but like I just hate running all the way back to get my shit and it's just annoying
I
Would just take a couple of tries
Folded me like a steel chair. I
Admit that is true. Well, there's one of those things up top there
Then I can level up anyways
Hello Krabos
All right, oh fuck you saw me
Okay, he didn't see me
But oh, I hate the crabs
It'll wait on later exactly run
All right. All right. All right. All right. All right. All right. All right. Okay. I'm guessing those are sea urchins and they would hurt me so
It's not fuck with those things
Do you want to like farm a little bit?
All right
I just like don't like I want to see if I can parry but I'm I also just don't want to waste health
Yeah, like uh
Like one hit just fucks me so
Yeah, can I
Yeah, I have to figure out the timing
Come on
No, see I feel like I timed that right
All right, I give up
Da-da-da-da-da
He shelled a pair oh
Look at me. I'm like trying to fucking parry and it's not an ability I have yet
What the hell
Why are you rolling up on me like that, bro?
Insha'Allah
All right, I'm guessing I can find a show with these guys or with the duchy
Yo, yo, yo
Halt trespasser
By order of the duchess all suspicious characters are to be bored from slack tight
Suspicious
I forgot the voice of them
Suspicious, I thought I looked pretty harmless downright adorable. Huggable even
Perhaps you speak of truth vagrants, but I shalt ne'er grant you entry twix these mighty gates
Whilst thy loins remained unguarded
Ex shucking excuse me
Dude take a hint she says you're naked
Oh, yeah, I guess I hadn't thought about that. Is that important these days?
I feel like society has really moved on without me while I've been practicing self-care
Sure seems like it
The duchess would have our heads if we let you in wearing nothing but a rag
Fret not little crustacean
nearby to the east layeth a repository laden with complimentary commentary
Face the gate you turn right you'll find a cherry center where you get something to wear
Captain is stationed right there now. I think great guy. He'll get you sorted
Sounds cool. Let me in
Assuming nothing sketchy comes up in your background checks. Sure. Just how the fuck are you gonna run a background check on me?
Okay, so I must be past the berserker crap then my hands just went
I have to get drip
I
Can't climb up stuff. Oh
Oh, how convenient what am I doing?
I like I stick in my little pocket
All right
I see a blinking thing over there
But I felt like I saw something behind it hold on
Hello
Are you fucking dead?
Wake the fuck up. What do you have an egg on your head? Do you have a ramen? What's happening?
Oh, I can't go past. Oh
All right
Durer show
Oh, I'm sorry. I'm just I still want to explore a little bit
You like her because she's dead. Oh, are these guys dead?
You know, you're in what you're into but I think that's breaking a law
Oh, no, I forgot to check on the last popsicle sticks that I saw back near the moon shell
Did you hear about the crab that went to the gym?
He pulled a muscle
What's she guys doing can I hang out with y'all? Oh, his legs are uh, you know, it's a good time. What this?
Captain there's a captain not around
Oh
Oh, it's like a it's like a little lobster neck tie thing
Oh the son of music. Oh, why are these?
I generally can't tell if they're dead or they're just tied to poles
I thought that was the shark dude for a second, but it's just a broom
And that is a gas thing. That's nice
And there's fishies
Uh
Excuse me. Why do you have a ravioli head and the other one had a ramen head?
Oh sick nasty brother
Do-do-do-do
Oh, are they all the same?
Yeah, seems like it. Okay. I like
this one
Oh
I can do the can can
Wait, that wasn't it. Oh, I accidentally took a screenshot
I'm gonna keep my little my little face on my little my little a real mouth. I think my a real mouth is very fitting
This shell chafes like heck compared to my what the hell
Found a weird it's got a can of my booty press old l1
So is that the parry because you said once I get a shell
Okay
Sick
Excuse me
What did you say you're so far away I can't
Hear you cross the ocean
Should be can bum
The voice actor went so hard I love it
Okay, I'm assuming. Okay. I got like chug jug energy in the bottom. So holy shit. Oh, okay
Uh, all right treason. Oh, let's go
All right, what else you got? All right
Oh, I pressed the wrong thing. Oh, I pressed it l2 instead of l1
There's a moon jelly location
What the fuck
Huh
Is that like the america thing
Gianni
Mattagrano stays America. No, it's his market
It's leaving with the fishes
Oh, let me stretch my leggies
Oh
No, no, I have a strap have a strap. So I'll bring him closer to me so I can jump between the cans
And I usually I like let the
Okay, can I like skip it? Um, although he's an amazing voice actor, but
Wait, where is he coming from? Oh, uh, I usually like to see what their move set is
But I kind of he just swings his thing and then also side dashes and he probably does a charge too. I'm guessing
Yeah, that's a charge
See oh, all right
Um
Well
Listen, I'm just
I'm just figuring out the game
so
Can you be nice to me?
Okay
Third time's the charm let's fucking do this
Oh, all right
Palms are sweaty there's vomit on his sweater already mom's canned spaghetti
I wish after like the third time this happens he would just stop
all right
Come on. Come on. Come on
Your
Oh shit
Oh
Damn
And I literally can't leave this fucking area until I beat him. Okay. Yeah, he is big range
We're learning
Hey, I never said I was good at games. All right, so
Take that with what you will
Body
It's kind of jarring to hear milf is an uwu voice. Well, we're gonna hear it all today, right?
I've been told I have like a big sister sounding voice
It's only when I get really deep and I talk in my
patreon audio recording voice
Then I sound like a mommy
What the fuck I went in my shell the timing is hard
I did it again
Okay
Can I switch? Okay
Oh he can donkey kick. All right
Oh
I should probably lock on to him
Sorry, I go I go non-verbal when I'm focused
Oh we fucking donkey kicked me
Shit fuck that up
Oh fuck me brother
Oh, I can like roll away
Oh
Can you believe the range on that?
I would advise against sucking justice out of his book. What?
Why have you done it? Are you serious from experience?
My image of playing you shooting me a pro CS player is quickly falling apart
No, I never said I said I wanted to go pro
I never said I was pro
Okay, hold on and you get some drink
She please I can't give you money. There's a seller restriction on stream elements. What?
Huh, I don't know what that means
Wait, have you guys been trying to donate this entire time from stream element?
I'll take a peek at that real quick before I go get some water. Thank you though. Thank you for supporting
Yeah, because sometimes the donations don't go through. Oh, yeah people tipped
They're tipped
I can't tell
Whoever tipped thanks for thanks for just the tip. Well, I sound like a zero
Yeah, I don't know. I don't know what's up with that or if you're making a joke. I don't know. Yeah, it doesn't work
There has been a problem with PayPal getting suspicious of the transactions. Yep. We got too many donors earlier
PayPal mark the account is sus. Gotta call this a fortune. Okay. Thank you. My next son
I'm suffering from success. You know what? You can put that money towards my merch quick merch plus
Actually, can we just look at my merch real quick?
Wait
Beep beep beep beep
I'll screen share
Fuck that go away
Window capture. Oh, we're capturing a window everybody
Holy great. It's a small window because I haven't
Narrowed down
Quick shameless merch plug everyone
Look what you can get you can get a cute standee
Oh, excuse me
That doesn't burp for you like I do
Okay, I can't scroll down. Um
But look at that. Look how cute I am with my I'm blowing a kiss at you
You know, you can cover me and kisses to you if you really want I don't mind
And then you can have a little keychain on me
And you know, I can't you can just pretend. I don't know my hair is brown at the bottom
Maybe it's like the coloring or the saturation should be red. Um
But uh, you can now pretend that I'm gonna whip you if you don't
Buy my merch, you know
Look honestly look how sick
This sweatshirt and sweatpants are
like
dude
You step out in this
All the girls dropping their panties. They're like wow. He's a man into bondage and big tittyed women
Holy crap, or if you're a woman watching me 1%
uh
You're gonna look so like imagine a little cute little crop top with some sweatpants
And you know you wearing your you can wear some docks with this like just look like a totally like
Gough mommy
And then look at the I think there's like a front picture
Look at that
My eyes are always and you could be like my eyes are up here and it's just on your tits
If you're you know, and we got lots of different sizes. Wow
Wow
Holy crap, and there's a shirt version. You know, it's really funny when we were developing
The design for this they initially had my hands backwards like
My like my thumbs were
Facing forward
So I had to send a picture
I sent a picture to scrawny of my hands like in this position that you see now and i'm like
Draw them like this tell the artist from ooloo market to draw them like this
So i'm just like pretending to be tied up with my hands above my head
So yeah, it's pretty sick
I love it. Awesome
My cat's on my desk
What are you doing big mama?
But uh, yeah, also look at the uh the other girls merch too whitney
Pretty sick pretty sick all in ooloo market then the description below. Oh my god, reina. What are you doing?
She's like, I must be held mother mother please hold me. I was about to get up
I was about to get up to get some water reina
Cat
She's purring. You know if you can hear that
Oh my god, girl, you are shedding so bad. I need I brushed you this morning. What's happening?
um
Yeah, maybe I'll like record her purring with a 3d. Oh like for like a cat girl
like
Snuggling with your cat girl and I just have like reina purring reina purse so loud. So does for you
Okay
I'm standing
I need to stretch. Oh, I need to pop that
Pop that throw that throw that shabussy back for a bit
I can't clap my cheeks like straw make it though
I'm gonna get some water and i'm gonna show it from across the room
Oh
Ice ice, baby
I got a little lemon water
My burrito broke and I have to get another one
Oh
Literally a cat girl
Yeah, I don't know why the price has come up like that for some of the items
It's really weird because I saw that for mine at 1.2. So I think it's some weird sight thing
It's a bussy hitting right just right
Fia my beloved
Yeah, Fia Fia's Fia's been through a lot
Um at one point
She had uh recently back in like march
She had some um weird thing going on where
Her legs didn't work at all. She couldn't move
Uh, they still don't know what caused it. They gave her they didn't know if she had some sort of
That she snapped her Achilles tendons. They didn't know if she had some spinal issues. We ran so many tests
They're like, oh, she has like the wobble syndrome and they're like
Then she didn't end up having the wobble syndrome or where you can't like cats can't move properly neurologically
um
and
Then another random like and like so many vets so many doctors were like
What but like they were they had never seen a case like this because like they ran so many tests on her
and my credit card is
Still crying
Because of that, but I will do anything for her. Um, why is the chat so weird? There we go
and um
And then they some random doctor was like, maybe it's toxoplasmosis and toxoplasmosis is like it's a
It's a bacteria or a virus you can get from like usually like pregnant women get it when they like scoop a cat's litter box
Which doesn't make sense to me. Um
But she
Or if you like eat raw meat, it's like the cat equivalent for like salmonella and um
My cat had that when she had an infection on the bone's intertail. Oh snap. Wow. I hope your cat's okay now
um
And so they're like to give her some antibiotics and so they did
And it worked
And she can walk and it's great
It's freaking amazing now she can she's still working on jumping because she's building up her confidence again
Because she couldn't move for like a month and a half
I carried her around in her little cat bed and I had to like hold her up to use a bathroom and stuff
It was very sad, but she's a good she's she's zooming everywhere now. She's my baby
She's like you might hear her screaming at some point because she likes to play with a little spring toy
And she gets really excited and she be house with it
But yeah, she's good. She's good. Don't worry about it. Um, she's I usually I have a cat bed on my desk
And her boomy and rena will sometimes lay in the cat bed
And so I usually I like to have a cat cam up so you guys can see the cats and then I can also like
flip you off um
in the
On camera, um, so yeah
At least she has you as a caretaker. Yeah, I'm very devoted to my animals
I growing up I almost became a veterinarian
but um
I was a slacker
I slacked
Wait, did did management finally tweet out that we have merch?
Hold on
Hold on, but yeah, don't worry about the donation thing so you can always support through patreon
um, patreon is also in the description below if uh, you can just throw five bucks my way and
Again, you don't have to consume what's on the patreon if you're not into that
But if you're like I want to help out or you know like comment subscribe
Wait or is it did they tweet I will retweet
I just I know I'm weird and I prefer Twitter on mobile
Oh
Why can't you mean no okay, they did oh crap
But um, yeah anything you guys donate uh, or like if support honestly just you just being here is support enough for me to be honest
um
But that goes towards my dream of buying my own house and having an animal sanctuary and also paying all my debt
because
Man, I love college
That party last night was awfully crazy
I miss your day, but don't feel pressured to buy like I don't want you to be like wow
You know Dami mommy she be was said I had to buy her merch
You don't have to it's great because a hundred percent of it the money goes to me minus my split with ubu market
But only what you can't I don't want you if you're like I need this to eat this week
Do not give me your money
And also make sure you support the other girls as well
Guilty us now or no no no no buy buy my merch. I'll be homeless. No, I'm fine again. Remember guys. I have a job
I still have a job like I would like to stream full time, but
that is
Based off of you guys. I'm not going to put the pressure
My livelihood on people who just want to sit back and watch a buddy girl, you know
Food is temporary. I am forever
No, no stop. Okay. Anyways, I'm losing my voice
Someone please help me with my monthly budget 40% for after
Finda no, I'm not into finda people somebody that has asked me that before
In my maros if I if I am one of the financial domination ones and I do not
Like that because sometimes people can be really taken advantage of
Not a fan of that
That's why I'm like only get what you can don't feel pressured
If you can't give it all just like comment retweet spread word of my
Terribleness to other people. I somebody's tell me that
In my maros that they're like, oh, yeah, I showed my my stream your stream to a friend and I'm like
oh
No, and then that person left a mirror. I was like, thank you. No, no the same person
somebody showed the stream to them and they were like
They left me a really nice message about how I reminded them of someone that they used to be close to in the past and it was nice
And I was just like, oh, I'm happy I could touch that person in a different way than I would normally touch people
What that sounds?
predatory
We went from we want fdom not fdom in this one
Just a little sus. Don't worry about it. She loves us. I don't love you
debatable
Yeah, I have to tell myself that or I'll get parasocial
base take actually
You can't get a pair of social guys
She hates us. I totally hate you. I hate you so much
You know what
Oh, okay. I think I'll stream it for a little bit longer
But if you I know like I think stronti is still streaming
But if you also want to watch
Amy when she starts streaming
Feel free to again. No pressure support all the girls all the girls deserve them the most
Law breaker. Oh
I don't know why I sound like prince. Am I blind?
Oh
I am blind
I pressed the right thing I will tell you that much
Bro, I'm
I don't
It might be me
But I don't like the timing of because I'll press I think the animation of me hopping in the shell
Like I have to do it before
No, I don't ma I'm not winning. I'm doing terrible
I tended to leave stuff because I'm about to say something parasocial
Bro, I get it. I totally I remember
When so I worked from home for a little while. I'll tell
Trigger it after I tell my story
And I like was very agoraphobic didn't leave my house for six months. Well, I um, I was like real neat
Hickey morey neat girl. Um
And so I just watched this one vtuber
Well, I watched multiple vtubers, but I was like, oh my god
I want to be her friend. She makes me so happy
My god, she's my oh she so like I get it. I totally get it
Like everybody wants that sort of
connection
He has never known defeat
Yeah, timing I'm still getting used to the timing
I think if I put him up against like the
I like I'm wondering if I will he kicks up. Okay. Well
Oh
And he also does the fucking back kick too though
Oh, is my game lagging no, well, I'm already fucked
I'm already fucked
Can I just give me a moment
Give me a moment, please for the love of god
I like bugged out for me to wear the shell
Oh, yeah, no, like
I'm trying. Let's go parasocial. Yeah parasocialism has its pros and cons because obviously it gives you something
but it takes stuff away because um
Yeah, you then you remember. Oh just a person on the internet
Playing a really cute anime buddy that makes you
Um
But
Like but it's totally natural to want to develop a relationship with someone that you have similar interests with and
But it just like
Understanding like oh, you know, I might I will never probably meet them
I never
Can have that sort of thing. Yeah, it's hard
I I I'm pressing circle. I'm pressing circle for the love of god. I'm pressing circle
I hate
Oh, don't back kick me, please
I hate that straw, dude. Why am I getting ganked by a straw?
Should be his tongue fellow
That's on my side. Why are you talking on that?
Why is he still talking?
Do you have tongue physics? I I can stick out my tongue. That's it
But I think it's funny because
artists never rendered the tongue
So I guess how about pink tongue?
You know what I should fucking do I should uh, I really should level up but
Yeah, I'm uh, I'm someone who falls so hard like
Like tomah said
Like when I care about someone I care deeply like the girls I'm like, I love you
You're my best friends now and they're like girl. We just met now. I'm kidding. They're just like me us too
We're all just fucking parasocial towards each other
My game is lagging a little bit. I just have to get them running in a circle and then
And then when he does that, okay
Some attacks are unblockable agro attacks
Signaled by the agro symbol that appears above krill. Can you see it? Be sure to dodge run or jump out of the way
Okay
If it's parasocial we're all doing it to each other
Can't escape para especially not in this industry you can knowledge. Yeah. Yeah
Girls of great chemistry. We do I know like, um
Some companies probably may not have that because some people like see
That as like, uh, fuck hitting it. I mean with enough tech smack out the balance. We never know. We capsize now starts to flash
Okay, so it's like a
Okay
Oh, please
I
Fucking up
Oh, I like I don't know why the fuck
That happened but it did
Huh, I like the artwork. Okay. It's fine
Now we know what to do. I think I was starting off while the freaking
Dialogue boxes that just shy to show up
Yeah, yeah, I got I got the strut I got the strut struts there struts all there
All right, bitch
Oh my god
Oh, you want to come get this crap busty so bad. Oh my god, you want this crap busty?
What the fuck was that?
I see that. That was so weird. He just like jolted to the side a little bit
Oh, okay, I did dodge in time. All right. I I'm pressing it when he's about to swing. So it's so weird to me
Holy shit that flings me back. Okay
Oh, no
Please
Oh, thank god
The
Oh, I thought I fucking
My nose is a chief fuck
I
Why do I feel like I've done more damage than I actually have
Oh, this is not a good show
Oh fuck
Oh
Fuck
Dude's giving you hella bot backshots. Yeah, not even the good good good way. This is a backshot roulette
It's fun to be a little parasocial but as a viewer, I don't want to come off like I don't understand boundaries
It's funny because tomorrow I have a drunk asmr stream and spoiler
It's where I go take you on a date and I'm just really drunk
So, uh, enjoy
Because I'm a lonely
wine hag
In the role play I usually don't drink but I'm gonna go out and grab some stuff to make um some mixed drinks
Uh, so if you fall in love with me tomorrow
You can't tell about a bite of my lip
It's okay
I understand
I
Make a drink of choice. Uh, I prefer fruity drinks. Um, I went to this really awesome barbecue spot one time and they made a
Uh, honey jack daniels with peach
Uh
juice and
Fresh peaches and ice and then some other but they made like their own like peach iced tea
And so I've been trying to replicate that for like the past year and it's so good
The lobster just stays yell he be yelling
He stay yelling junk on a Tuesday junk on a Tuesday afternoon
It's gonna be four o'clock for me, but it's five o'clock somewhere. Am I right?
All right, is it gonna do that weird shit again? I don't know
You're
Oh fuck
I'm trying I'm pressing this and it's like just not
Oh, he's about to kick me. Okay, that's good to know what that that's what that looks like. Oh, shit
Oh, why was I doing so good the other time and I can't do it?
I
Can't get him. Okay. I see to get him running in a circle and then I gotta time the
The parries air quotes
Did I burp I didn't even notice
Yeah, I need to get them get them started that's what I sometimes do for a lot of like
Horse riding or like mounted enemies. I just like running in a circle
All right sugar tits about to mute this game so I can focus my hands are also fucking sweaty
All right, come on
Mm-hmm
Circle around this dead body while we're at it
Oh
I knew he's gonna fucking do that. I was trying to roll out the way
I
Fuck me
Yeah
Damn
He was up my ass. Okay. So I kind of have to make sure he's far away
Wait, no, I'm not back sitting. I just noticed animation when dark souls circle strafe is so good
It is to give enemies mine which gives cops it
Literally penetrate it from behind
We getting better though. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah, we learn and we learn and
You know wipe my controller I got cute maroon controlling
I wish I could just skip this whole thing. Oh I'm already doing it
Shibby stay determined. I am I'm actually feeling pretty good. I'm not I'm not ragey yet
Because now I got the strat and it's it's just it's mostly it just falls upon me
Hello
Uh
I
I'm I'm guessing maybe it's like for friendly stuff that if you fuck up too many times he just
Let's you go
I'm kind of mad
Is that supposed to happen
He's just like fuck this I can't I'm gone. I'm gone. Is that like a game feature that if you
Can't do it that
I'm like yay, but I'm also like but I wanted to beat him
I
What the hell
Uh
Okay
Hold on well something happen or something be different if I go to the guys
Yes
What the fuck cut off my job, bro
Uh
Is it a bug?
Hold on I need to look this up. Um
What is it what is his name what was the what was the guy's name again
He's hydrating we're underwater. Why would he need to hydrate nephro? Okay
There's a child screaming down the hallway or a dog. I can't tell
It's a dog
Uh
Shell spells I just spoiled something for myself. There's a shell spell
Okay, yeah, I think it definitely did bug out
Uh, excuse me
That's so weird
You've returned to the dishes kid in the kitchen and go clean some dishes and make me a sandwich
You know what I would say so like I play like valorant and stuff
um
I was a viper main and
I would want to be courage and I would try to talk in a viper voice
Don't ask me to do it because I can't do it anymore. Um
But people be like, oh
Getting like they'd say the stupid shit like same as counter strike
Getting the kitchen and make me a sandwich and I said aren't you a man?
Don't you have a war to go fight and die in somewhere and then they shut up?
Go fight isn't there a war to fight go fight in a war go get enlisted
Stop chilling in your mom's basement
Go fight in a war if I'm in the kitchen fight in a war
Hawk of the area vagabond doth grace our gates pray I would have seized up open the gate, Nate
You got it
I gotta say I feel like there's an awful lot of violence around here
I thought the whole point of the duchess was to make things safe
Go tell her all about it kid. See how cool can you get kicked back to your tide pool
Newy newy newy oh, hey, what are you doing?
I don't it's weird because it looks like somebody's standing behind him
Wait
Look at this fucking he's doing jumping jacks. What does he have? Is that a is that a used to cute tip?
Go get enlisted is crazy
I'm doing nearly the only one out here, bro. It's where is everyone?
Hold on a second
This is cardboard
We're underwater
I'm not quite sure how that's holding up underwater
But it is oh, it's over here
Hello
I like the little caps
It's actually pretty cool
Nothing important back here. Oh, why don't I believe you?
Go in the caves. What is that? What the hell?
What is there am I supposed to like climb up there at some point? That's really weird belligerent blue
SpongeBob mechanics quick good asking
Industrial strength cardboard truly and yeah, I would literally just like disintegrate in the ocean
Oh shiny pins
Hey, can I talk to you? Oh, I'm sorry
I don't know what you want up this tower, but no chance hatchling. Don't you have more pressing?
I like all the guards are like lobsters
Oh my god, people are fucking screaming outside my door. Um
It's also funny because I ate lobster today
And guys, what should I have for dinner today?
Microplastic flooring is crazy. You got to go in the goon caves for character development
Uh, I have to wait in line, right?
Are they wearing clothes?
The gentry is wearing clothes. I don't they're like socks in like shoes
That's so funny that one's wearing lipstick. Oh my god. This is what did you do guy?
Oh, is that a mustache? Okay, maybe he's just a short guy my king my short king
Sheebie how short is too short for you? I don't care how short you are
I'll step on you either way if you're tall get stepped on if you're short get stepped on
Hey
Where do you think you're going chum?
I'm gonna go see this duchess lady. Oh, yeah, just gonna walk in and see the duchess, huh
What do you think we're all standing around for?
Go back when you have an appointment like to actually do the gap in her schedule
Our royal duchess is just sitting walking for the next 15 minutes
Wait, huh? Oh neat. I'll head on in then. That's funny as fuck
I was just a mercy laugh. I just did
Here or there
What's in this room?
No, no way supposed to clean up back there, but I haven't had a chance yet. I want you to see it
Wait
Are those uncrustables
Wait a second wait a second wait a second wait a second
Uncrust worthy's
Oh, can I please get an uncrust worthy please?
Oh my god
Same height laying down
You know, I always like didn't so like growing. I remember there was just this
Couple in my high school and she was like 411 and he was like 6-4 and I'm sorry, but I was like
How fuck does that work?
Like
How does how does anybody reach anything?
You know like I'm sorry
Chat's average height is a Chad tense date. Are you lady dimitresk the fuck?
Um, I'm sorry. I'm crust. No, I can't be uncrustable for dinners. I need to go grocery shopping
Look at my shiny booty hole. I mean
Sorry, uh that hole
Booty crab shell
Wow
Does this crab have titties? Why are they so well rendered?
It coming and she has like a t
thing
Did she ride on her shoulder like a master
Oh, I kind of want to smash this crab
She sounds like lady dimitresk and I think that's why I'm like, oh
Should I just start talking like this to sound more haggie and mommy
Oh, yeah, uh, definitely. Look, I can oh, yeah, uh, definitely even more gorgeous than the
Smash or smash uh
Smasher and then an eater because I fucking love eating crab
My parents would take me to those like little china buffets where you can get like plates of crab legs and I would just slam them down
Well, somehow maintaining my childlike
Under a hundred pounds figure
Absolutely the reefs are super
Oh, perhaps we can work out a deal
Do you want my body? I'll sell you my body
My castle still lacks a certain
Panache
like gorgeous
Oh, I'll be speaking France
You know out on a whole other level
You want a bore? I'll bore you
Crab duchess mommy
Magister
Nobody fucking cares. He's just like something's wrong and then we just like totally normal. All right to the west
Do be do be do like over here
Oh
Cool was this the western tower area
Okay, wait is that um, I thought that was a moon thing
Is that a kitty cat here? Fia, what are you doing? She just went
Oh
Hey
Wait, that's
This is the east. Why are you letting me this way?
Hold on. I just want to look at the uncrossed or these uncrossed
Shockers
Mario, are they supposed to be malboros?
Grape jelly in mozzarella, what the fuck?
Elden Bay
Old Bay seasoning is so fucking good. I put that I put that shit on everything
Good morning. It's 6 p.m. Where are you? Just kidding
Sheeby would like to know your location
Hey, you're not gonna tell you try it Mario mentioned Nintendo is coming for their aspects
Oh, you are
Why are there so many sea urchins when I bet if I bumped into it that'll hurt me
Hey, can I get by here does it look like it
Is shipment of the fort's defensive urchins got spilled out across. Oh, that makes sense
Touch us up in arms. She's always executed five people. Oh, jeez
Oh
Fucking hell
You need to like stay on the mission
And
You know what's up there, can I like oh can I like hook?
Whoa, what the fuck I can jump thing
Can I like
Can I
Wait, what was that?
Okay, um, why do I feel like I can hook that but I don't know how
The fuck am I supposed to get up there?
Oh, not platforming. Oh not platforming my worst enemy
Oh, what the fuck, you know a game I used to really love and this is reminding me of it a little bit
Like bare minimum just because it's I'm like wall
Running although wall crabbing
Uh titanfall I fucking loved titanfall
Play this shit out of titanfall. I wish I'm sorry, but fuck like I hate apex legends like I hate apex legends
Apex legends took another titanfall away from me. Um, I like
titanfall 1 and 2 I've played both I recently titanfall 2
um
And I really I like the plot of titanfall 1 though
Timefall 2 had amazing. Yeah timefall 2 had amazing multiplayer and then I like destiny because destiny reminded me of titanfall
And then destiny's gone to shit
And like I put so many hours into destiny like I just played um
I was playing recently like a little bit last year
The not the recent like not the final shape
But not the one before that one either
Because I went in the game and I was just doing like the normal like I was replaying old plot and I'm like
What the fuck happened to this game?
You want me to pay 60 dollars to be able to use
A dumb ass power like I was so irritated
Not no, I will not bungee will never get my money
I'm so tired like I I used to love overwatch. I loved overwatch
But then
Like this the loop box shit and the micro transactions and I'm like and then games are just being so
Expensive for no you can't I wish you guys I need a 3d model because I'm very animated with my hands
And you guys can't see how much I'm moving my hands
um
uh, but
it's
I just get so far I'm like, why do you want me to pay this much money to play a game that's already out?
It's just a dlc and it's 60 bucks
The only excuse I'd give that to is elden ring. I don't know how I don't know how much elden ring
Erie tree one is gonna be though
No fans, but they said destiny 2 would get its root back last three. Yeah, no that that game is
Shit shite fellow hand talker, of course
Oh what the fuck look at this little animation
That's so adorable
What the hell um
Oh
Wait, can I can I have that?
I'm a balder skate
Like it's weird because
I
love fantasy
And I thought I would really like balder's gate
I've never played balder's gate. I had never played diablo and I like diablo
I'm usually not good at like or like
Not like not good, but I don't like turn-based games. I realize
um
In like party management and like I like the story like if I could just run around like a skyrim and just like
Gang people that'd be cool. But I think because it wasn't what I like. I literally have balder's gate three sitting on my ps5
Because I bought it and I played like three hours and I got nowhere
And I'm like, when do I get to fuck a starion? Like I just want to fuck a starion
the vampire dude
Who apparently is the also the voice of hyzenberg?
From a resident evil village. Hello
What I'm playing on easy difficulty
Uh, sorry about 20 20 77
Yeah, sorry about 27 7 redeemed itself. Good great game. Great game pan am
hell yeah
Did can I have that? Oh fuck, you know what? Give me that
I don't know where the fuck that came from
But like
I won't lie to you
I love fps's, but I haven't played any like I haven't played cod or black ops and I haven't played um
Valorant and I haven't played like because everything's just so different and I just
I just can't
Stand them anymore and I'm like because I played like I played counter strike. Um
Oh, come on. I played the newest counter strike and I'm like, no this doesn't feel the same like I don't
I don't like it
It just felt whatever
And everything I'd like it was like games used to be so much more simple
But now with like skin like like oh like the counter strike definitely introduced like the concept of like
skins and like it was literally its own little
system
Little stock market. I know that for a fact because I spent thousands of dollars on stuff, but yeah
Staring as the hardest romance
Difficulty just track through one
But I pretty sure I had it on easy mode because I like usually I'll play a game on easy mode
I'm not afraid. I'll say it. I'm a little bitch
Um when it comes to games that I don't know so I'll usually play stuff on that
That
It caused generational trauma to my imaginary fit. What?
My friend group more like half-life pvp enjoyers to gorgeous. Yeah, I never I played a lot of gary's mod
I never played team fortress. I'll be honest with you
I played so much trouble in terrorist town um and murder
So I supposed to do this
The fuck is that
Dude
I'm like pretty lost
Oh
Okay, let's start a piece of string. Amen. Oh, okay
I was like, I see all these fish hooks. When am I gonna learn to like grapple?
Okay, well, I don't know where to go though
Am I too far away?
What the hell
The fuck am I doing?
Oh
How was it watching she be? Oh, yeah, she was like stuck platforming for like
An hour. It was great
All right, do I need more string? I don't
Should I just kill myself in minecraft?
Oh my god, hello
What
The fuck dude it would have let me go up
I hate it here
I think it's because I need a snack and I'm getting grumpy
Oh
Don't do this to me again
What what is that if why wouldn't let me just go up straight
Getting angry maybe so this is gonna make matter race platform. Oh, no, it's literally always the platforming the platforming pisses me off
Can I
Oh, that's cute it's like a uh medallion badge thingy
That's real cute
It's an adaptation
I'm guessing those are powers
He's so cute what the fuck
All right, Blake
Is that the only thing I need
Oh
Listen it takes me a while to figure out objectives
Can I why doesn't it let me go?
I love crabs
I just got yeeted for some reason but you know ended up being helpful I guess
Okay, all right
Because I'm like I don't know if something's a bug or if it's a feature
Ow
I could definitely just walk around stuff though. I don't know why
Do I need to oh
Oh, no
Yeah, fuck I keep walking into shit
Hey, do you got any spare hearts on you?
And I feel like I'm spina man
Wait what? Oh
Come on
Oh slow mo though. Oh, that's kind of sick. Oh shit. Can I get up?
I don't
All right
Bull like uh
Where do I go after that?
Crab game makes me feel it's actually you know, it's I'm actually crab man
All right, but they do
I'm not I'm not touching that. I'm literally just walking forward. Fuck
Please
I literally just swung through them. I don't know how that worked but go off says
No
Kill me kill me now kill me now
Your shell is badly dead shut the fuck up
I
How am I supposed to that's what I'm supposed to be doing, right? I'm gonna krill myself
Can I walk around this I can't
I can't ladies and gentlemen
Wait was I just supposed to grab the stuff in here and then leave I
No, but she said so that the tower I don't fucking know my shell is blinking
Oh
Okay, imagine it I was about to say imagine I died
Oh my god
Fucking dying because
It was like oh imagine if I fucking I was about to say imagine if I die and then I died
Why can't I reach please
Okay
That's stupid as hell
I need fuck I need clothes. Can I just run in can it will they let me in?
Please I don't
I don't feel like worrying about have to put on clothes. Oh, thank god
Goofy ah death shebe's left shoe
I didn't even take out do a fucking double take because I'm like what
Oh, I didn't know my left shoe could talk but all right. That's cute
You know what I also saw that was cute people putting my oh she marks on their name
That's very cute. It makes me happy
Never thought I'd ever get to a point where people want to oh she me and it feels very nice. I have to say
Oh
Was that another fucking bug it's supposed to stop
Do I like lose all my micro plastics like I lose like runes and shit
Oh my god
Am I wrong am I wrong or does that thing get stopped by the wall and then it just didn't do it that time
I don't know why people would want to subscribe after that but go off this
It is a souls game bugs are features and so it's like that is so
That's funny as fuck
I can't even get mad because it's funny like if I was watching that and you just like I'm like oh, I just get
Oh, this is funny
It's funny
I
Because it stops like right there
Oh
Ha ha bitch oh
It wasn't supposed to stop right there
It was supposed I wasn't supposed to try to spider-man my wake. Okay. See I'm not bad at games
That was not supposed to be the mechanic to get up there
It was supposed to go by so I could walk up
Oh my god
This game's killing me, but in a good way. I like it
Oh shell, are you okay? I can't believe I dropped it. I'm so stupid
I one job and it was oh, it's your fucking fault
Yeah, he he we had a date and he fucking stood me up your captain we were supposed to battle and you just left
Skip the boss we get slowed down on the stairs, but then it just oh my god, I can
I
Was so like I was so ready to fight that boss too. I'm so mad
But I'm like happy, but I'm mad. Was that a marshmallow?
Do I get a little hat?
You're telling me I could put this on my booty cheek, but
Am I got that cut pussy?
But um, but I couldn't wear that snail shell
Barnacle
Oh, that's cool
Damn you get on a lot of stowaways right off the bat. I wonder if that's normal
Oh, okay
It's for attack vitality. Oh, I see how that works and then you can get more and promote. I'm oh, I didn't mean to do that
Ooh
Oh, okay, so it's either one or two in this and that
defense
I'll do that. Yeah
Doesn't uh
I need to go to a moon shell. What the fuck
What is this?
Drop I don't want to drop. Where am I dropping?
Did you say something to me hand-pressed and then make it a bit as interesting as I were
Can you be favorite?
Yeah, sure thing chicken wing
What's that do
Now we're gaming
Gotta go. Oh, of course. Bye
If you guys you leave you to watch how cute Emmy is totally understand
She might be like looking some of your ears right now or something. I think she's ASMR today
Oh
So that's the re oh
Okay, so if I fall I climb up
So if I didn't drop that I
would just be fucked I
presume
All right, all right
We're here we're vibing
I feel like if I touch that it's bad. So I'm not gonna
I
Must be like oil wait, what's that there's cool stuff up there
I mean down there. I'm sorry
Excuse you
Give me your micro plastics
Oh, I wonder if I can just like jump down
I probably can
I'm tempted but then I have to do all this shit again, but I don't really care too much
What that
I don't know what the shell means
Oh, it's pretty cool
Oh
Can I like
Oh, I thought I could like
The fuck I wasn't locked on
Can I have that?
Ew, I don't know what that does
I'm more into drunken bunny ASMR
You're just gonna see how much of a babbling idiot I get
Is there
Is that where the cave is supposed to be I thought or is that someone else
An effort to recover his home the plucky hermit crab ventures to a mysterious cave
But he quickly discovers that return journey will be significantly more challenging
Hello, who's talking he approaches the ghostly figure in front of him
I like that
I'll be different from now me good. Hey, let me just
And then getting banned
Oh shit
Well, I have the nail so I already have a tack up. Okay. I'm good for now. Yeah
Or I can put because I got a small but the can can get hit so
Yeah, that's fine. Oh, you're so cute
Who's talking
Hi, um, my name's krill. Do you know anything shiny in this cave?
Something that might like impress a huge beautiful crab lady
Yeah
Confused and desperate the hermit crab begins begging help from strangers
Hey, I'm not desperate
yet
Thus far he is preserved persevered by taking refuge in artifacts from beyond the waves
But to survive here from here on out. He must awaken the currents inside of him
He must access the power of
a mommy
A mommy
Mommy, sorry
You know the voice acting crazy in this game
I mean drunk funny content and some of the best
I'm looking at a bite. I'm looking at a bite
Wiggles eyebrows
You mommy I'll stop
Food wars rough should get out of here food wars is so weird. I'm like I
I really like food related enemies and I was watching it and like I'll fall asleep to that
But sometimes I'll like wake up and people will have their clothes off and I'm like
Why am I
Why
Never I'm not gonna finish that joke
What
What the shell was that I feel tingly
The hermit crab crab dawns a metal shell and feels a new ability awaken
I do
Yes, he does
While wearing a shell press book to consume umami charges an evaporating new shell spell. Oh, that's cool
Oh
Shell shock or fizzle that's so cool
Can I talk to you again?
So what's this umami stuff exactly the hermit crab continues into the cavern excited to make the use of its new ability
Uh
This is like I'm not gonna fucking talk to you
I
Creature blocks the hermit crabs path immune to his physical attacks. It may only be dispatched by his newfound umami powers
Well, isn't that convenient?
The noble moons now denies any involvement in manufacturing the scenario
How do I is it really seemed to me
Oh when it touches me
It just
Oh, that kind of sucks actually it has it has to hit me to be affected
The one's innocent hermit crabs ability to slaughter his enemies has increased dramatically
Did you have to put it that way
Your voice is so nice for how dorky you are
You wanted a dummy mommy you got a fucking nerd
Are you supposed to like charge the shell and then block? Oh
My model's lagging, but you're probably right. It's probably probably blocking
When I have my controller plugged in I have to have run my model off of my wi-fi and so
I'm gonna move in slow motion for a bit
He senses that the reward he seeks lies further within this cavern
As well as the opportunity to meet his newfound idol the mysterious and attractive moons now in the flesh
Guess I have no choice
I kind of wish I gave the moonsail a dorkier voice than like a hot
Lady voice pop off interesting
Keeping the shelf for now because of the defense, but I do want to oh look at the sea anemone anemone
um
He can just to play around the stuff. Ooh
Don't fall into the abyss
Can I okay
Sometimes I keep pressing l1 sort of I don't like that it does that that it sometimes it gets stuck and doesn't climb up
And I have to wiggle around
Whoa
Why am I getting beat up by this stupid thing
Eep
Oh, it's on the games. I like it. I like it
Uh, you guys can let me know if you'd like me to continue this. Otherwise, I'll probably just like play by myself
If you guys like watching this
Me trying to dumbly figure out a game
What the hell
Hmm
Do I want to try to get over there
Because I'm just gonna get caught. Yeah, I'm just gonna get caught in a stupid net weird net bug
All right
I'm coming for you
I'm pressing the wrong. Oh god. Oh god
Abraced r2 again instead of r1
I
Whoopsies
What's that
Oh the charges my umami question mark
Wait
Can I guess I can
I
Don't need to fight you
Oh, I see there's like little parts where I actually can't climb up. What the hell
That was a weird ass noise that crab man
The animation for the grappling is pretty pretty sick
Okay, that makes a lot more sense now because I'm like, why can't I wait, but I just did it right now
I'm confused
Oh
What the fuck just happened
I'm so confused
I just fell into nothing twice
I thought it was gonna drop me
Back at the moon
That was so weird and then the can fell that I had I wanted to have two cans up there just in case
Oh my god, I don't
And I have to use a stupid shell shock one. All right. Come on, bitch
Oh
Look at me. Look at me. I am de-captain now. I am de-captain now
Get absolutely fucked
What is that is that a button
He's not gonna be a crab game too. That's for sure. I can tell you that sugar
I thought of the
Hold on now. I have to look it up the Pedro Pascal. Oh shit
The fucking okay the Pedro Pascal thing
Oh
Yes, this one this freaking tiktok can I please play it?
I don't want to log into tiktok
No, where's the where's the thirst cam?
Is this it
Oh
I need to learn that line
So you can scream my name as loud as you need to sugar. I think that would be good just like a
Southern mommy dom's you
You can ride me and scream my name, you know, I think that'd be pretty nice
Do that for a patreon audio I have a an ASMR script I have like lying around that's just um
Wait, can I
Oh
Sick if I fall I don't have to go all the way back. Okay, that that makes a little bit more sense. Okay
Wait, uh-huh
Does that say go back? I don't know
but uh
I don't know what I was saying, but uh, yeah, no, I have a uh
Southern bell ASMR that I wrote um where the
I play naturally the love interest. Um, wait if I let him will he just spawn them for me if I just go idle
Uh
I actually should actually heal
um
I play the love interest and then
the listener plays the childhood friend
that went away from town for some years
and
I just
I missed having you around the farm
And I need a big strong
person like you to help me out again
And I've been so so lonely
And I really missed you in all the fun times we had by down down by the creek
And yeah, when you said you were not gonna platformer you meant it
Fuck you. Um
You know what this you this crab you get cocked get get
That's funny Freudian slip. I'm not into NTR. I'm genuinely not it's fucking stupid
Oh
Little man hanging hanging on. I'm so sorry. Is he still?
And I'm free free falling. This is can that's fine. Wait
Shit, oh fuck they move
Oh, they actually hate me they actually want me to suck
A limp it. Oh, I should call you guys limp its
Are you my little lip it my little lip it?
Yeah, you guys are stuck to me and if I try to remove myself from you, you'll kill yourself in Minecraft, of course
Can can I come back please?
Only on cold days
We have so many names now slut whore bitch harem pussy cunt
So many
I'm getting
railed
You do be do
What's over? Hey, you subred co in it
Oh
Somewhat. Oh mommy. Oh god
Uh, what's that a shot glass?
Yo
Damn
I got some see-through panties
Oh
Wait, it's only 70. I thought wait, I totally misread what the defense was
This is defense 70
How does that work, but it's so tiny
What is shards? Oh, I don't know we'll figure it out
You got a butt window
Well glasses salt. Yeah, that's true. You would be correct. Oh skizzers
Hey mercy was here
By the way
You going bud
It's over here. Oh god
Oh god, what's happening? What is what is that? What is that? Oh, I need that though
Okay, let's see what the shards I can't get a too small
Oh
Oh shit
Oh, but it but it breaks fast. Oh and I died
In the arms of the angel are you
Fucking me right now my model is lagging so bad that I can't even
All right, uh
We're gonna end we're gonna end that here we're gonna end that here
I'm not leaving yet though
I'm not leaving. We're just ending the game here for a second. I just want to hang out with you guys. Just chat
I'm gonna just hang out
Can I save and quit? I don't know how to leave
How do I leave? How do I leave?
Chat chat chat chat chat. Hello chat. How do I leave? No kidding. I figured it out
Oh shit
Where the fuck do I trade it though?
Ooh, this is pretty skill tree
If I get like bugged I can just die instantly
Oh, and it's a recycle. Oh, that's so smart and cheeky leaving us. No, I'm not leaving you
Let's go back to my bedroom. I'm gonna take you back to my bedroom madam. She can have an encrusal. No, they're mine
Listen, I'm a lonely person and I have nobody to talk to so
I'm gonna talk to you guys
Otherwise be talking to my cats
Yeah
Dragging us into your bedroom you're coming here not against your own will. I don't know what you're talking about
You know
So
Honestly, yeah, actually I haven't asked like what do you guys have for like feedback for me by the way like, you know
It's only my third day out here
If you want to be honest if you want to be like, hey, she be
You could improve on this or your gameplay sucks. I already know that though or
If you have any recommendations, you can always send me recommendations for games in my murals
Fiat isn't a good conversationalist all my cats are Siamese. They don't shut up so
Yeah
Good burps keep them coming burp better. All right, uh two sides of that coin right there
I'm pretty proud of myself. I got through not far in the game
You're less dummy mommy than I would have liked I get that a lot
um
I don't know how I can
Be more dummy mommy
on
the internet
Like besides like obviously in like my patreon. I could be like get on your knees and take the strap but like
If I'm playing a game
like another crab stretcher
I want to be like
Slams you against a wall
grabs you by the throat
You're my little discord kitten. Aren't you aren't you the
Peasiest stupidest little bitch. I hate you because like all I could do is like insult you
That's the extent of what I can like I could be like
Get on your knees
Although I actually do have a crop
my crop go
I have
I have a riding crop that looks like denticle to the one that I'm holding
So if you misbehave
But this will be for membership streams
God for bitches and tommon it will play your crab souls like
I got this and she be
He's
You guys are fucking with me um
And what else do I have I have this
I also have a cat paw one
I also have a ball gag that I got keep the little heart one from throne
Thank you guys so the people who've given me throne gifts because what I want to do is like
Eventually when donations work
like you could be able to like
pay
To have me do stuff
like oh
for 10
Five dollars I can gag she be for five minutes and she has to put the bell gag on or um
Uh
I know that's like subby
But I think it's funny because then I can try to talk with it on and then try to keep streaming
Um, and then for the crop I could just I don't know saw my ass with it
I don't know if I'd be allowed to do that on youtube
I meant slap my hand because that's what I'm doing right now
Slapping my hand play blood born
I want to play blood born, but I don't have a capture card. I mean, I totally have a capture card. What are you talking about?
um
Like twitcher deems. Yeah, like because what I miss about twi- like I really liked redeems. I hope at some point that youtube
does
Something similar because that'd be fun
Um, honestly, you're doing great. It feels like you've already become comfortable in your new skin dealing with us. Yeah streaming
I I could easily like streaming is so fun. I love streaming. It's not hard for me to stream
It's not hard for me to yap and talk at you. I'm not like I could be a shy person on my hand is red from
slapping this um
But uh, that's usually like outside of streaming and in streaming I can be
I feel like I'm more myself when I'm streaming
um, so I like I I take the opportunity during streams to beat myself
And I hope youtube gives this gumbo currency
Streams of jjk chapter leaks. I don't know what that is
You're very active while playing games. It's hard youtube is engine the way to be a streamer folks
Yeah, which is nice and they're doing like I don't like tick-tock related shit with like the forts and stuff
um, I haven't put it on any more shorts because again, we want to be able to put ads
I'm not ads, but like run
put money into them
but they keep getting nuked because of my
My uh, yeah, so I don't know if I'll be able to get monetization or my first few streams might be demonetized because of my
bitties
I don't know I could be totally wrong
I
Like that a leash has physics
Are you a good puppy or are you a bad puppy because if you're a bad puppy
I don't know if you'll like it when you know, you're a bad puppy. I'm not hitting you with this. It's going up your ass
I
Not me waiting for a ribbed sweater. Yeah, that'd be cute like a cute little like I would love that for like a fall outfit. Um
A little like cute sweater like a little sweater dress
Body con sweater dress would be pretty hot. I have so many ideas for like, um outfits
I want to do hold on. Let me come a little bit closer to my little my little puppy dog, which is you
Are you good?
Are you behaving?
Um
But you can't dual wield that tip of
Maxi dress. Yeah, like a maxi dress like sweater dress would be super cute
Um, but I also like I would love like I've already mentioned like the tan gyaru thing or in like
that I mentioned like the bully
Like school girl high school bully
Um outfit and then also I want to do like golf outfit like golf dummy mommy outfit
Then I also like want to do victorian gothic lowlita
Uh, um outfit and then also like
Pimp brothel madame outfit like there's so many
Outfits I'm like
outfits
Bunny girl suit. I'm already a bunny girl. What more do you need? I might like I'm wearing
I think I'm wearing less than a bunny girl. I should know they're wearing like a leotard
Gothic little yeah
Optopic but water is the best drink. No, that is off topic
Are you are you thirsty bud?
Take it take it take a trip take a drink
Oh, I'm goth. I know stuff
Okay
John, you know
Mommy she be madam. She be had her goth face. I know stuff too or like a C
You know when I want to I want to see emi as a scene girl
Hmm
Emi is or mercy as a scene girl. That'd be funny if you all had like emo
Outfits that'd be sick
Mafia boss get up. Yep, and I can just talk in early bad jersey Italian accent be like look what they did to my boy
My beautiful boy
I
Fast food employee. Oh, that'd be fine
I did a a role play once
um
where
I took chat on a fast food date to mcdonald's
And I had like a little car asset and like
Stuff going by and everything and I'm like what you want everybody. I had a kid's meal and it was really fun
I like doing skits and stuff and just like, um
Improv role playing. How about nursery beat? Yeah, could be a nurse teacher. She'd be like I
I want to get glasses for my character for my character for myself
This is me. This is what I look like
Um, I want to get glasses for my for my model
That'd be fun and then I could be like really studious
She be is a jolly sense of bee tubing. Oh my god
She be with me again or like, um
You said me again, and I just thought of like morgana like that sort of like sucky bussy sucky bussy outfit
Nurse she be with the suppositor. No, you're getting an enema
Again an enema
Can't confirm she be is a bunny in real space
Is not in real life in real space
Teacher she be suddenly the time for ran hands
Ball sculpting rope
What does that mean ball ball sculpting
What do you mean by ball sculpting
Oh
Yeah, well those will be like patreon
Stuff, you know, uh, it's interesting in it. I feel kind of bad because so like
I've recorded three months of scripts. We were all given I think like
Um
A couple months worth of scripts
And I recorded like three months worth and so people are like, oh my god
I can't wait for this audio and I can't wait for this audio and I'm like
Some of them yes have already been made but some of them
Have not been made but I know strani is taking a lot of suggestions into account. Um
Someone's like, oh
Like I need this audio and I'm like, oh, that's not that's not coming out till next month and I feel bad
Triple back lay out. No, I I recorded a lot in advance
So I would have more time to focus on like us some safer work asmr's too
um and just like some skits
Because I like like I said, I like asmr skits and just like I like dramatic reading and stuff
um
I want to like I've mentioned in my last stream. I want to
Maybe do a podcast as my friend or we just talk about smutty books
That would be really funny
I'm maybe like pre yeah, we're pre-recorded talk about smutty books. I don't know if that'd be allowed
But just fun. Um
She beyond that grinds it. Yeah, again, like I want this to be my full-time job. Um
So I know strong it'd be like, oh, can you do this and I got like I'm I finish it immediately
um
I still I was telling you record
September's audios. I haven't did I record? No, I didn't maybe I'll do that
tomorrow
Perhaps especially because yeah, like I'm streaming every day this week and probably next week
I'm beating you with a frying pan ASMR. I will eat that a meme asmr is coming
It was supposed to be out when we got monetization spoiler
um, but because
Starny is worried about us getting demonetized mean is there right off the bat. We haven't haven't posted it yet
um
But yeah, like those really silly
Uh
Mimi ASMR is I definitely want to do some of those
I just have a thought that considering she loves women fan pictures in her mirror once people start getting merges in me
Yeah, um, I know some people have speculated about my orientation. I'm pan. I don't care what you are
Give it to me. No
Give it to you
um
I just uh
I grew up drawing a lot and learning a lot about art history
And I just love the human form. And so I've just admired all parts of the human form
so I think it's
Uh, women are beautiful. Men are beautiful and handsome women are handsome. They're just nice
Oh, yeah, isn't that cool?
Um, happy crash. You be happy bad
It's I don't really I
I actually don't tell people that you guys you guys are in the know
I don't tell people that I usually keep it by myself because some some people tend to make it a whole
character trait
That doesn't need to be one clavicle. Oh, I love me a good some good collar bones
We got a chance boys
As long as you get enough rest and don't burn yourself out like that
See what you're cooking up for us. Yeah, of course like I
I'm not working right now. I'm currently on leave because of some medical stuff. She's mad. Hannah. She's mentally ill. Yes, uh, whatever. Um
I also just have like chronic pain and all that stuff. So I'm like, let me take a break
I was missing a lot of work and so oh my god, I seem to go on leave because I'm already missing work
I don't want to leave me. Yeah, um
So I don't go back to work
Officially until June 17th, which is my first starting day back
so
I'll probably be streaming every day because like in them like I stream at 4 p.m. Eastern time
So like I got plenty of time to like do stuff in the morning and like relax and again
um
aren't we all uh
I'm a fairy like I just live with my three cats. I like
I'm lonely
So like
I can be a little
a little fairy
And I can miss you guys
because that's why
I'm on here
past my normal time
because I like
to spend time with you
Sorry, the the bun speak um came out
I
Love the crazy cat lady. Woo crazy cat lady asmr would be good. I like that
British kids you just like a like a chop like
Just like a london herb heavily bronze
Just shakes you
That's so funny. Oh, yeah, I was I was like I was talking to my parents
I like oh, how you doing? I'm like, I'm good. Now. I'm like thinking about getting another cat
And my parents are like why and I'm like, I don't know. I'm feeling more lonely and they're like you already have three
What's it gonna be? I'm like, I don't know. So like I got
Boomi so reina could have a friend and then reina hated boomi. So then I got
Fia so boomi could have a friend
But Fia also hates boomi because he's a menace to society. Well, she doesn't hate them. They actually love each other very much
Um, he just likes to chase her around and sniff her ass too much. That's kind of annoying for um, and I'm like, maybe
Fia needs a friend, you know, like everybody needs friends. Everybody needs friends
Don't say a poor boomi boomi like what do you do the other day? He
Fucking attacked my feet. I was like I got out of the shower and he
Has this weird thing where he likes to be held right after I shower. I don't know why he does that
I'm like, oh, maybe he wants me to smell like him or something and he gets really snuggly and purry
So I'll hold him a bit and then I put him down. He got mad and he started attacking my ankles
Everyone needs a friend
Yeah, and you won't be sleeping, chilling, eating. I'm surprised they're not like running a muck right now
Boomi, boomi isn't a crate. I I had to put Fia in a crate for a long time because um
Boomi would try to pounce on her and play with her when she couldn't walk
And so um, I had to for her safety just put her in a crate
But now boomi and reina and fia just like sleeping in it
I didn't know I could crate train a cat, but I crate trained a cat. They're actually all crate trains. So
Cats are really pretty cool. But I like dogs too. I always want like when I get my own house eventually
um save up and all that stuff
off my debts
Um my house I want to get dogs. I really like great piranhas
They're so big and I want to get some like because great piranhas are livestock guardian dogs
and I would like to um
Get some like chickens and goats for the dog to protect and my friend told like taught not told
Taught me but she tells me how she makes like candles from goat's milk
And her candles smell fucking amazing because she does like those like farmers markets and stuff
And I'm like yo what doggie brings you like I like big dogs
Small dogs are yappy. I used to be obsessed with huskies
Cats are cats territorial. Oh, yeah, not really like it really depends. Go smell because they're mentioned
um
I like
I remember I really like feral hounds. I also really like coon hounds like hound dogs. Um
One of my close friends recently had a hound dog that passed and I loved him so much his name was copper
He would be like
He was a sweetheart. Um, I usually I usually don't like um
hound dogs, but
He won me over with his floppy ears and his like he would like almost like purr like a cat when you pet him
He would just be like, um
He just pet him. He's like
It was funny
Yeah, he was he was a nice old man that old boy
um
sweet sweet boy, uh
and
I also want to get a dog because again, like I said, I'm a woman who lives alone
So I would like scary dog privilege for when I go on walks and stuff because I I don't usually I hate
I also have really bad anxiety going outside. Uh, like I said, I was a gore phobic at one point and I feel like if I had a dog
It would be I would have a lot more
confidence
A dog named copper as well. He's rich back. Oh, yeah rich back religion rich bags. Uh, I have the weird talent of being able to
Look at a dog and almost guess it's breed exactly
Because I used to my grandfather got me a dog book a book of dog breeds when I was younger. So I'm very good at um
Identifying rough area. Uh, where I used I like I moved down to my parents house. Um, that was a rougher area
Somebody got decapitated like a block away
That was crazy and a kid got stabbed in the butt in my high school. Um, but
Uh
Where I am now it's a little bit better, but people are rowdy
And excuse me. Yeah
It's crazy out here. He's crazy
Um, yeah, some kid that was like gang violence got stabbed in the ass. Um
And that's good
But I think yeah, I remember I was looking into like dobermans for a long time
Because I was like and then I was like, oh, how much would like an actual
guard dog be
They're like $40,000 and I'm like
What?
Uh, I used to work at a dog kennel
for um protected protective dogs
I hate I only lasted a week because the the way they treated the dogs was terrible. I reported them to um authorities to like, um
Animal control and all that stuff because they were a hundred percent
of using the dogs with uh shot callers and other
Methods to prop to improperly train them for for guard guard dogs a guard gone is only 530
Yeah, I want to get my um my license as well for that
I think it'd be cool imagine the IRL stream where I was taking to a gun range and I'm a good shot too
You know when I was in camp I got a Davey Crockett award because I'm really good with airsoft rifle
Um, but yeah, they had I love Belgian Malinois, um bellmells are so awesome. They're so smart
You know like I I also want to be able to get a dog that I can work like I don't want to take a dog to get bite training
um
Take a yeah, take uh get a dog that can
Like do agility courses and stuff. Um
And they also had like a rottweiler. I think his name was huxley. He was such a sweet boy
He was like, you're such a doofy little guy. I'm like, how are you gonna protect anybody? You're too sweet. Um
And they also had a lot of german shepherds
uh
one of my
co-workers
Could I be your cart top? Sure. You guys are all my little my little dogs
Put you on leashes and put those little puppy masks on you
um
One of my co-workers at that place another big reason why I left one they only lived in like five by six
Kennels like it was so small kennels and that's where they were 24 seven
Unless they were taken out to train and it was bad and they didn't get like walks. They didn't like I wasn't allowed to pet them
couldn't pet the dogs
um
couldn't have any sort of
interaction with them
um
I remember I was almost bit by this really beautiful black long-haired german shepherd calls called her miney when I was giving her her food
She was like and I I know it's because they're trained to do that. They're trained to be
Aggressive, but like it was just not the right way to go about it. Um
I'm pretty hard to be horrified
um
But my we were taken one of the dogs slipped out of their kennel and
Like I said, they're very aggressive
I didn't say I left me. I was like correctly and he
decided like a freaking asshole
to um
Hold on. I'm taking my cat mouth off because I'm
frowning this guy was a piece of shit and I hope he's
fucked up somewhere. Um
he was egging the dog on and
she
Launched at him and tore up his sweatshirt, but his arm would have been gone
uh
Because he was just like trying that I was it was messed up
I was so pissed off and then I reported the company reported that employee
and I dipped um
And you know how I said they lived in only like five by six things
Uh, that's where they peed and they pooped and they ate and so my job was to go in and just clean their pee and their poop
And so I always came home smelling like shit. My mom hated it
I had to get special boots and I had like shock back all her piss and then pick up their dog. It was bad
It was so bad. I hated it there. They're gone now. I'm so happy. They're gone
I'm very passionate about animals
I remember when I was younger I also wanted to be a wolf um conservationist and biologist
and um
run a wolf sanctuary
and so, uh
It's just like when like animals don't have the same
Comprehension as humans and they deserve to be protected. Do they pay good? They did not I think I got paid like 12 dollars an hour
Or less than that like nine dollars an hour
um
But yeah, I was
I've had a lot of interesting jobs in my life. I know I was telling strani about one particular job
That she's like, oh you have to tell
You have to tell your stream about that
And yeah, because I used to I used to be an intern for drama alert
That's all I'll say though. That's all I'll say on it for now. Um
um
Let's get right into the news
and
That's crazy. Oh, yeah, you guys you guys don't know you guys don't know
Um, if you weren't a bunny, what would you be instead?
Does he know
does he know
Where you were hanging I wasn't hanging out with him. I was in a group chat with him on twitter
My job as an intern really all right, uh go out scour the internet
And tell him give me some stories
And it was funny because I was also working with celestia vega at the time
If you don't know who celeste vega is she was one of the zoeberger girls e-girls um
And
We would just I remember just chatting with her and we would just be like, uh, what about this news thing and she was just like
I don't know. I'm gonna be like this news things doing what drama alert is good
He don't need to know
Um, oh my gosh, but oh, yeah, yeah, no, and he was uh very well connected to the commentary community
very interesting place, uh
It's when I first became a vtuber. I almost became
a drama tuber
But I
I wanted and I probably actually might still do this
Not be like report on news, but just um
Do you like synopsis of
creators
Kind of like a like a I know I've been watching
Uh, who was I watching recently? I like was recommended like a rima evan star even star video about like bow the whale
um
And what happened with that and I I just I was really I was like, oh, yeah
Like that's exactly and that's the type of content that used to make was that sort of stuff
If you don't know cook stars to stay that way gossiping stream, I wouldn't be so bad
but like that's like I wouldn't I would only
comment in like
document
Things that happened. I wouldn't
Want to gossip because one I don't like gossip and it's kind of catty
And I'm not one of those types of girls
And I wouldn't want to
Step on people's toes by being like, oh my god, there's person in eezy song you did
And then like all that shit like that's just
I'll leave that to false
In the press new soggy whatever his name is
Yeah, documentary documentary deep dive stuff. Yeah, like and you know like I
You know, it's really funny the people who used to watch my commentary videos
Um, we were like you should do ASMR
Because I talked in a really wispy voice because I wasn't super confident
So I'd be like this time in this community. I would just uh and some people are like, please I'm falling asleep
But I'm also entertained
Please do ASMR
Surprise
I'm doing ASMR
I'm gonna be real hella respectful for that. Yeah, like
I'm not like I'll like I won't lie to you. I watch those
channels
Can I be honest with you right now? Can I be can I be real with you? Let me get real close to
I've only been a vtuber for
Maybe
Six or seven months now
So I had to do a lot of research about the state of the community
So I watched a lot of shitty
Stuff I watched a lot of like drama
Drama alert. I watched a lot of like drama tubers
Um, I had to go back and figure out who the hell marushia was
And why was everybody hating on her because she was dating so-and-so
Like I I did a lot of research
about
The vtuber community prior to being a vtuber
I always I watched vtubers like I would watch clips like I watched shy like I watched like the mainstream people like shy lily iron mouse
Um, I watched them from time to time, but really just clips. I wouldn't sit and watch streams
and um
but
So I did like a lot of freaking research. I don't know like strani was in my interview
She was wary about hiring me for a second because she was confused because she's like you've only been a vtuber for five months
How do you but why do you know so much?
and I'm like
Because I was a streamer for five years before that
And I do a lot of research because I know how to do research and so I know a lot of stuff
So I only have a couple months on strani for vtubing experience, but I love it. It's great
I remember I tried vtubing back when it first popped off in 2019, but um
I uh
I yeah, I had like a v-royd model and I remember editing it. It was really fun
I didn't even have like a character. I she just had a red hair
And like maroon hair and like a purple outfit. I can't remember like tan skin or whatever
um
I dived into the matrix during oh, yeah. No, I do my research. I like to be educated like when something happens
I'm immediately researching it. So like for example, that's a reman even star even star. I don't know perhaps her name um video
I was like
I didn't I haven't watched it yet. I saw the thumbnail and I'm like, oh looks like I have to go back in time and research
on what this was. So I watched like several different videos and looked at different um tweets and was like, huh interesting
I'm a secure. I'm just someone who just loves absorbing information and um
Vtubing is definitely one of my special interests. So I will hyper fixie and try to learn everything there is about it. Um
Yes, I was before this
Yeah, I had so in order to apply to be a lurid you had to have um some sort of experience of streaming under your belt
um
and
The scrawny preferred a long lengthier amount of time and in my interview that's when I was like, oh, I actually
I've streamed five years before that. I've been in content creation for longer
But yeah, but I I went down that rabbit hole
um
But yeah, I like I love deep diving on the internet. Um
Another thing I'm just I they don't they don't know this. I'm just like mercy. I am a
Allude ASMR virgin
Um, I never made
audio content like that before. Um, I
did like I teased a little bit
on stream
for my uh, my past life
And like tried to read like skirting the edge ns of w on twitch
and um
That I was like, but I'm like, you can't corrupt me. I'm already messed up
And the she forgets that the minimum that she said you could apply with was just drawing stuff
And I drew a lot of smut of my character and I commissioned a lot of smut art. I'm like, so um
And in my in my audition, I didn't even do anything
Uh, lewd. I was just like, hi, I'm redacted and this is my redacted for vealer
Can you give us a sample of your ASMR? Well, you'll get that tomorrow
You can wait until tomorrow
Or you can I don't know go to my alt account or whatever
I hoping the alert is a male gen. I'm sorry that will never happen
And strani said it in her exposing vealer. We will not have a male gen
I'm sorry if you want to honestly
There is such
Like I think what will be cool about vealer is that people will be like, oh, yeah, that's right sex house and um
I won't be surprised if like like, uh
Not like needy, but like somebody out there with like a lot of money is like, you know what I want to make a male
um equivalent of vealer, um
But yeah, because people will be like, I know like people probably like, oh male gen because you want to make the content too, but like
um
people some viewers will anticipate like
Interacting like with um
talents from other gents and like
What's unique about vealer is that although we do the content that we do which is ASMR lewd roleplay content
We are also kind of
In the vein of japanese idol stuff because we don't
Talk to guys
And like they're fine and all um
But also like
Like strani said in her exposing me a lure video
uh
She's not a dude
I don't like we can't
We can't the management company
Then strani can't they're not dudes like can't
How are they gonna advise dudes like if they're not dudes, you know, no femme boys
I'll be the the emmy could be your femme boy
Gender bent no
There's death. There's so many lewd tubers out there. So many lewd tubers
There's male lewd tubers that you can find that make that sort of content
So you're not gonna die if you don't get femme boys at vealer
Well, we're on the topic of the old stuff. Do you saw the cursed ass monkey and
I need everyone that yeah, I do
Wait, no, it's long this it's not on this though. Wait, can I
Hold up
I don't know if it's I don't know if it's on this computer
I have a very funny picture of Ed Sheeran
Let's see if I can find it
This might take me a minute, please. Oh, oh shit. What the fuck?
Nope, nope, that's not it
Oh
Guys, don't worry. It's worth it. It's just gonna take me a moment to find
Um, but as for like past life stuff, I'm I'm probably not going to talk about it. I know like, um
I know that
I know that, um, Amy did but
That's
That that's another I'm moving on to a different chapter in my life
So I'm not really gonna brush on it. If you know, you know, if you don't then sucks because my past life was awesome
All right
Yeah, this is a great great image
What is that creature
I
It's Ed Sheeran
Okay, little monkey
All right, let me get rid of that. Um, yeah, we whatever you feel like doing is he coming or is he returning?
Is he returning an iPhone?
This is me every a psycho eyes. Yeah, you know, I don't like I want to know what picture
They took that from like obviously like they just like put his face on this person in an apple store wearing a monkey outfit
But I'm like where's it's like so well deep faked
Um
You do you mind diving into my past life? I'm not really any different to how I am now like my void like I was
I was um cute and funny in my past life
That's really the only difference, but like I did the same things
I'm still the same person. I'm just a little bit more
Dummy
Um
But all my content scrub, you don't you might be able to find a clip somewhere, but I doubt it
um
Capacity of sheebie dunk of
basketball, no
too short
All I think I know about your past level you're supposed to be a brown cat girl, which is like 50% of youtubers. Yeah, literally
Cat girl, that's all you need to know
Can you do some green screens? It's mostly being oh, yeah, yeah, that'd be that'd be actually pretty smart to do
Um, I was thinking about that the other day because I was going through
Like the pictures I post I just take them on my phone
Um and vtube studio on my phone because I've exported my model
And I'm like, oh, I should use the green screen so people can like use them and put them in be like
Put them in silly memes
Same just a dump. Yeah, essentially and then I just make
naughty content
Check out my patreon
Um, can we get black hair sheebie probably do you get past life flashbacks?
Not really like I was a very small creator like I wasn't like emmy or anything. I was very unknown
Um, so that's why I'm even more thankful that I'm here
Like I'm very thankful that
scrawny picked me and nobody to be part of this
Because she saw something in me. She said she saw a 2.0 version of herself and that made me cry when she told me that in the interview
um
But uh, but yeah
Yeah, but
You don't okay, just because you don't have to talk about it
So that's that's the end of it. That's the end of the past life talk
She's she's gone
She's she's been let go
Because I'm determined to
move forward with she be and make vealer
a um
An amazing place. I want like people are like, ah
vealer is gonna explode in a year
Like how are these girls are going to be gone? You do not know how determined we are to make this like when you have a
person like
scrawny um
Heading things like you and like some of the reeflings know like you want to ride or die like
Uh, we're all so motivated to make vealer
amazing, um
Um
And we're like, oh, they're gonna have woman moments. Oh, they're gonna. Yeah. Oh like but we all got good heads on our shoulders
Um, I'm really proud of the other girls how like mature and talented they are
vealer is not here
For a short time. We are here for a long time and a good time
And uh, yeah
You can freaking clip this
And really you could you'd be like, oh, let me clip this so that
We see if his age is terribly it won't
It won't we have so much stuff planned
Can't wait. I'm so excited. I'm so happy to be here. You guys have no idea
Um yapping is literally what we want. Yeah, I'm here to get
All the ladies seem absolutely fantastically. This would be not an exception. Thank you. I appreciate that
Um and even like
Like again, like I said, I was small. I was a small vtuber people
I had like maybe like max 20 people watching me
I already feel like I've succeeded. It was my goal to be in a in a corpo. It was my goal to join an agency
and I didn't
I didn't expect to have 11k views on my baby like that
Boggled my mind like I never thought people would actually want to watch me and that people thought I'd be entertaining, you know
But I'm I'm just happy. I make you happy and I'm happy that you find me entertaining and the other girls are entertaining
Like I like watching the girls like again, like I said, I don't usually watch a lot of vtubers
But I will sit and watch strawny for hours. I was watching her a little bit. I was watching icy
Is there like they're all such wonderful entertainers to
She really picked good ones
Um
So I didn't read his character till I should be yeah, I remember. Yeah, uh, somebody like asked if I um
I'll I'll give you some all exposed to be alert some more
I'll tell you who we all went for
um
In terms of models and how it ended up being so much better that we didn't get who we wanted
Um
so
Again, like as I mentioned, I was I was cute and funny in my past life. So I went for
Pins I went for well, I didn't go for like anybody in particular
But I was hoping for like I said, please give me anybody but I was hoping for pins aka emi
um
And it's funny because emi
I think was going for mercy and mercy was going for icy and icy was going for emi and azura was just azura
Because she's just perfect for azura and then strani strani, but it was just funny
And then we're all here and we're all looking at each other and we're all like
I wouldn't want it any other way. Like I feel
Really good being she be and everybody else is so good
being
their respective
People and we're still like learning about ourselves and like getting into the characters and like
Getting the kayfabe and like we're still like so thank you for your patience with us
And yeah, like I think it worked out in the end. I hundred percent worked out in the end. Um
You cute and funny what you don't
You don't think I can be going funny. I don't be really going funny. I don't know what you're talking about
My mom
Yeah, it's gonna take something like I can't wait. We're gonna learn we're gonna grow and we'll make mistakes
And we'll learn from those mistakes
And we'll take the feedback. We'll take the critique
We'll take the trolling with a grain of salt, but like
I just I can't wait to see where we'll be a year from now because in a year gen two
gen two
Maybe after that gen three
I just want to help strani build like just
realize
her dream and then
This is a dream of mine to be part of something bigger
You know
I think I always stop pretending. It was a crab game shooting in the goth
And then one year two fast no actually like what I've noticed recently is a lot of
Companies have been putting out generations like six months after and I'm like I thought that was too fast
um
And I think a year for v2 like the first generation to get it established is pretty good
So no, she's an investor detail is an investor
She's an investor
Sean is our creative director. We have management. We got editors like we have this whole team behind us
Um, I feel like six months. It's hard to get established
as a
especially like a first gen um
So I'm happy we have a year
And like another thing
But then you can argue like okay, if you've been streaming longer before that in your past life
Which most have been like because let's be honest a lot of the
people in
corpos and agencies right now are already formal corpo and agency girls like
Ex Sundaria members x this x that
Um, so they already have that stuff under their belt. So it kind of makes sense when they go into another company and they're like
Okay, you're good. And then they send another like sick because there hasn't been like I think
Villalur and even like you may plus have been
uh
in recent
Years like the only companies to hire brand new girls if that makes sense because like
None of us like none of the girls in Villalur are former corpo like we've all been indies before that
So then we all really worked really hard to be
in Villalur, so
Yeah, Jenny it doesn't seem so
Yeah, um
it you know
It really depends I think it really depends on the company
I know some people like beg for second gents because to be honest they probably get bored of um
The other gen or they're just like okay. This gen isn't my cup of tea
Can I please get another one? And so I think that's another reason why companies put out
Agencies so fast because they just want to appeal to the masses which is not what you should
Which is well, of course is like you should appeal to them, but you can't just accelerate in your company
Just try to find try to hit like one person correctly
that everybody likes
You know ball gen one. I know I want to get a bald toggle. It's like
And this is my ears
Very embryo glad hearing voices. Yeah, I like was
Really worried I wasn't gonna get into Villalur because I wasn't a former agency girl and like I'll say this
So like I mentioned in my 2.0. I applied for like 10 different auditions several different companies
um
And honestly it was kind of stupid of me to apply those companies because at that point I didn't have any
V2 being experience only normal streaming experience. So I um
This is kind of they're like why is this flesh person applying?
Um, and then I applied as appeal to a couple of them and it's funny because then I like I look at like
like I applied to vnu
And I look and I'm like
You know, I'm kind of happy I didn't get in because they fit their characters so well, you know
And um same for like idle and stuff. I applied to idle. Um
and I was like
I don't see myself like they're everybody like fits their people so well, you know
It's hard to see them as anybody else or see myself as one like oh, I could have been a better version
like I don't I don't ever really say that because
yeah
Most industries are passing around the same people especially entertainment though. Yeah, there's always a thing of like nepotism
um
I know
Yeah, like a lot of companies
Usually like we'll have their talents vouch for other like indies or a talents from like
Former talents from companies and stuff. So it's like, yeah, it's pretty common in the um in the entertainment industry
Clapping with no handlebars one, excuse me
She be as Kai
um
This is a very long invitation to show business. Yeah, like what I like what really attracted me
to
Vila and honestly just like straw knees ideas in general was that she isn't
Uh
She's kind of breaking the mold to my voice is cracking
Of some btuber standards like for example, she doesn't care if we talk about our past lives
So that's why and we talked about hers and you probably already know the other girls past lives and I know some of you know mine, but um
Uh because it's like taboo normally to do that. Um
Or just like having a collab ban for the first week like I could collab with an indy tomorrow
But I'm settling in a she be first. So that's why I haven't done that indy or another kropa girl tomorrow. Um, also like in terms of
The transparency with how much they pay us like all that stuff
Do you know I know your past lives? Yes. I do know who you were
I'll do I'll do like a past life regression stream where I just
Pretend to spiritually know who you were in a past life
How can you get a job experience though getting hard? Yeah
That's not yeah, it's like that thing where companies are like
Oh, you must have eight years of this and the company's only been open
Like or the industry's only been around for like two years
So like it kind of does make sense that there is a lot of nepotism in the industry
You know because they're like, oh this person
Wants to join a corporation their former agency kind of you know, shit the bed
Let's give them another chance. We've seen their content. They know how to do this this and that
So like it makes it it is like business wise
It makes a lot more sense
To do that instead of like a bunch of nobodies like
Like me
I could have been completely crazy
I still am crazy
Was I a frog? Uh, no, you were a salamander. Sorry
Entry lover job five years experience
Ask catch them as who employers want a 10 year old 25 years experience letter
This girl isn't skit so hard
Um another insider information
Everybody in the vtuber community is mentally ill
Everybody's got a touch of tism or something
So when you're like, oh sick girl corpo. Yeah a lot of people you may in this day and age
Everybody has something
Everybody's got something. I'm telling you that right now
Like I'm uh, I got fibro. I got dysthymia OCD. Um, what else do I get?
If I haven't been diagnosed with ADHD, but I probably have it
um
generalized anxiety like
Everybody's got something
Especially with like how we communicate nowadays
It's like social media
Hello, I'm an anime girl right now
Um
and
I wish someone would touch my tism
um
and like honestly
A lot of like we know a lot more about mental health now anyways like
Like my dad, for example, like he a hundred percent probably is adult ADHD because I am my carbon copy of my dad
I'm just woman form
We are exactly like I have something called adjustment disorder
As well and he definitely probably has it
And I'm like if I get tested for ADHD and I have it
And I know my dad has it because I didn't really know about that stuff back then, you know
um
I used to work in human services and all the people I used to support were
Institutionalized for the longest time because he didn't understand these poor amazing people and how they just work differently
Will they form
Every day I see something that makes me want to get tested for autism
Yeah, and then on the other hand, there's a lot of people that like self-diagnose when they are like kind of put on
stuff so that they can feel
quirky with the label, but you know, that's another conversation
um
Daddy Davey when
I don't know probably I'll probably I think like strawnee said she'll
She'll have her dad or in record a video with him about like guessing vtuber names
And I might I might yoink that idea and do that as well after her
I took a google quiz and it said so and I took that like I don't know what's called. Is it like rad's test to test you for autism?
because my chat
In my past life was convinced. I had autism. I don't have autism
Um, I just really like slime. Okay? Um, and I get distracted easily
um
And I did that test and I scored like 104 which is like high and they're like medium indications of autism
I was like I literally was like
I was like non-verbal for like two minutes because I'm like wait do I have autism
Then I'm like no no no it's like these silly things on the internet the like you're like
Everyone loves slime slime is awesome. I have I have like a bunch of slime. Where did my slime go?
It's on my it's on my bookshelf
Um, definitely like slime stream slime ASMR stream. Um, I'm just chat is so cool
Uh, yeah, I I do have a zoomer energy. I do have a zoomer interests. I um
despite being a high
We stay sliming we sliming up in here. That's why I'm begging for a slime girl for gen 2
because strani's already conceptualizing stuff and
I've seen some of the concepts and you guys are not ready
And I'm just like but um, can we please go slime girl?
No, what hell you don't need today. No, I don't know, you know, I could just be quirky. I could just be weird
I could just be odd
Sometimes you're just
you're just
A little bit different than
Society's expectations and but that doesn't also mean you have something, you know
hag love
um
I also want like a vor chuba. I mean what?
There's a lot of like, uh
Tags and kinks. I think that would be funny
for that sort of stuff
We love older women hag love
hag love
Some people are just not like the other girls. I know, right? Maybe she's born with it. Maybe it's Maybelline. Eat me mommy
My face went funny there
She was on that deviant art, you know, I was on that deviant art, bro
Although I was on deviant art because I was making really cool photo manipulations of dogs and wolves because
that was weird
and I was an avid wolf role player for
10 years
I'm saying make myself sound older than I am
No, it wasn't 10 years. It's more like
We love a drop of yado vtuber and my life is yours
Wolf of rabbit's clothing. Yeah furry affectionate. Uh, I probably was a furry, but I don't think I want
I just really liked post-by-post role play like I'd be on like role players guild and stuff because I like to write a lot
I love my creative writing class in school. And so I just um
I
I was on this website called like wet paint, which is like
Site hosting place and a lot of people did like role play like whether it be like warrior cats
Or like human role plays gifted role plays. Um, all that stuff
And I was in a lot of like wolf, uh role plays
and dude
I thought those were my golden years. I was no life and I think pewter for like eight hours or day
Just being a wolf, but it was just cool because I know I was I like I'm not only child. Um, so I had
No one to talk to you. I still just hung out on the internet all the time
and just did uh role play stuff
Howling at the moon. Oh
On all levels except physical. I am a wolf
Um, but I remember one of my favorite things about wolf role playing was, um
Oh dude
First of all wolf quest
Wolf quest learning that side note learning that doki bird played wolf quest
Made my life because I thought I was like the only one that played wolf quest. It was funny on my pl
I had played wolf quest like, um
Like a couple months before she did and I was just like
Because I used to do role playing on wolf quest. That was a gay. Oh, well, we're gonna play wolf quest
I have wolf quest we're playing it. Um
And now you tell other people to bark for you exactly. I still told people to bark for me back then
Wolf quest the real origin one went. I know right. Um, but uh
I know it was a g
But um
I used to do this it was called it's gonna make it sound like I did a drug
But we there was a type of role playing called speed
So speed role playing was one sentence post by post role playing
But you had you would get hits
On the other character because it was it was like fighting you get hits on the other character by how fast you type
So if I managed to um
Type faster than you did a sentence of me doing an act and you took damage then I then I beat you
Um, and then there's like a certain amount of hits you would do and different like you had a cross distance
um, and you had to I show speed and you had to um
Uh, like get certain holds like I remember it was like eight
Hits to break a spine
or like six hits to
Get the throw and you could like throw people off. It was really fun
Um, so I had like a hundred plus word per minute
Yeah, it was really it was actually
In Minecraft. Yes, of course in Minecraft. It was really fun
I think that was like I I prided myself on being such a fast fucking typer
um
I can't do it now though. I think my words per minute is probably only like 60 or less than that
Punchy. Yeah, I was running around punching people in the spine
Um, I think what I liked about role playing as well
It was like I could take out aggression because we would raid other packs and go on their website and raid their chats
and just start fucking marking people
out I
I killed children. I killed pregnant children pregnant children
I killed pregnant wolves and I killed children. I took lives blood in my ma
um
But uh, what do you think of your chat? Um, I get
I I'm also like mercy and I get can get motion sick. So I can't do VR
So VR chat like I've done it without VR headset, but it still makes me a little bit dizzy
Not the young links
Um, but yeah, I was I remember the crafting really cool stories. I think I have like
I think oh, maybe I could like log into my super fucking old email and try it because I remember I saved some posts
Of um some role plays that I did with my friend. Um, because we had like our ocs in your role play with each other
and then
We had like a almost like a john carter esque like princess of mars
role play. It was really funny. Um, and then
Like I think I had one of like a really dramatic
Posts of like my wolf character dying
Um, but I yeah, no, I I I really miss that because I love creative writing
I would I remember my dad um said that and my mom were like, oh, she's gonna grow up to be an author and that did not happen
but um
Yeah, writing's fun reading's fun for me. I haven't done any of that stuff in a bit though. I've been
It just sucks when you get like older and like real stuff gets in the way, you know
Like life adulting. I'm like, oh, I have to have a job
Oh, I have to pay bills
Oh, I have to take care of my health and well-being
I can't just rot away. I'm like what I'd give to be like 10 again. Just do fuck all, you know
If you dig john carter read jane carver of war interesting
Does she we have a bunny? Yeah, I have a bunny tail. You can't see it on my model
But I do have a bunny tail
Oh
Yeah, adulting does suck. I hate adulting like I was um, I was talking about my alt this morning
I had to like go to the bank because I lost my bank card
I'm like, I need I'm late on my rent and the banks were closed over the weekend
And I couldn't pay my rent and then it still wouldn't work
So then I had to write a check and then I had to remember how to write a check and I'm like, uh
Being an adult
Shibi when you were a fnaf kid. Oh, I love fnaf, but um
Like I watched the fuck out of uh markiplier playing it, but I never
Was like super into it
um
Like
I think like in me super into it
It's so hard after 25
Oh, I gotta be dom life so hard
Good bunny tail
It's hard after 40. Oh, don't say that
Well, I'm far away from that. I got quite a ways to go, but my parents um
Oh goodbye model
She she's she's asleep. Um, my parents just like
Had their like 30th
No, they're about no, how long have they been married? I don't know. They've been married for a really long fucking time
My parents just like started entering into their 50s. Um
Ha that still doesn't give away how old I am
You don't know how old my parents were when they had me so fuck you. Um
But uh
Just like what they've been dealing with I'm like, uh
I don't want
Like when I was younger, I think I lived past 18
So like it sucks to be
No, no, no, I'm in minecraft in minecraft
Minecraft
Um, um, yeah, I was I was in the baby the belly
Yeah, no, it's really yeah, because you
Why am I really depressed is because I was diagnosed depression. I was like 14. Um
Like you
I didn't
We're getting real real we're getting real deep right now and it's only my third time streaming, but I don't get for shit
um
I like being honest with you guys, but um
When you're always down, you kind of don't see a future so you don't work on your future. So like I didn't
Really focus on
Like going to college a lot and focus on this and I focused on that. I didn't like pick up certain skills
um
But
In hindsight and like and obviously like hindsight's always 2020 like I wish I wish I could like give my little younger self a hug
And be like you're fine. I know you have severe social anxiety and you can't talk to people
Um, but you're gonna be okay and now you're talking to hundreds of people on the internet
And they like to watch you and talk about stuff. Um
But but you know things change and I'm I hope the same for you guys like if you're um
Younger or like um
Going up to I know like I think a large part my viewer base is like in their 20s and their 30s
but like you know hang on there man like
There is
I don't know why I'm being motivational, but there's light at the end of the tunnel
You just have to find something that you want to
Work and live for for me. It's my cats
and uh
Realizing my dream which was to be a content creator and entertainer. So you guys are helping me
With my dream and I'm a little happy and then you know getting like mental health stuff and like um
And uh, what's it called?
Like getting the right support
Everybody has different situations ain't no cure for these brain worms. Yeah, there's never a cure
But you can always make the most of it, you know
um
It's all like fake. It's only make it or just like find other
uh
support systems
Chats average ages through 76 stage
I brought a new 77c tv that's almost like a family exactly retail therapy is so great
Um
And I mean I'm such a dummy and I'm giving you life advice. Oh my god
Workout playlist is gonna create. I know I need to start working out again
Um, I like put off working out for streaming and stuff, but now that I'll be part-time at my job
I'm like, yeah, now I can go work out
And then again, I want a dog so I can go for runs and not feel like I'm gonna get like abducted or something
dominating you emotionally. Yeah
RFA streams. I don't know what that means. Uh, someone also asked, um
If I like rode horses and stuff, uh
I used to do a lot of different things because my mom was so like
Bless my mother's
dearest heart because she tried so hard
To like have me find an interest that wasn't being on the computer and doing games
So like I did horseback riding
I did ice skating. I did gymnastics. I did ballet. Um, I did a lot of
Stuff I almost did track
Uh, yeah, I did a lot of different like act active hobbies
um
It wasn't even bougie like
I didn't do them for long
Because like growing up I was really fucking poor. Um, my mom broke her fucking back
um
to
put me into the thing like
She would rather me be happy
And doing an activity to keep me engaged being an only child and everything then like
Get something for herself
to be honest
um
Honestly, yeah, again shout out to my mom my mom
Side note my mom just fucking lost her job today. So fuck her
Her company's went under fucking sucks. So like I hope that I can support like I want to be able to support
Like I know strontis is like, yeah, I paid off my parents house. I'm like, oh if I could fucking do that
Like it's the time it's my it's my time to
To give back
To my parents, you know
They were like, why are you a whore and you have such a good relationship to your parents? I don't know
It's always the christian girls, is it?
When you're hyper repressed
This is what happens
Boney
Hey, stop fucking fighting for you. Hold on my cats have all just woken up and they're just fighting each other now
Raina, I need to put you up to
Stop what are you doing to her?
Don't get dick. She's trying to sleep
Going
Wait, where's the score bottle because I know who he's already acting up. He's gonna start
I
Don't like
She is just like screams. He probably heard her like
Like making funny noises in the background going
Because he's like was biting her throat. I'm like, dude, you're killing her
He could he just plays too rough because he's he's my he's my first male cat
I've ever had I've only grown up with like female cats and I'm like, oh god
Maybe I should get another male cat. So he has someone to like
wrestle with because rain is like 14 years old she
But she she's the she runs this shit. I'll tell you that much
Fia's the baby
Boomi just turned a year old and fia just turned a year old. Um, but fia's
Much smaller. I think because of the issue she had with her like not being able to move and walk her
Her like muscles astrophied and she was she's really really small
Like she's literally the same size when she was a kitten. So Boomi just fucking beats the shit out of her
So I have to there's like a clip out there somewhere of like Boomi like
slamming her on the ground. Um, well, I had a cat cam on it was so sad. It was like
Far cats is like, oh, I'm getting myself bigger when I'm trying to scroll up. Uh, whatever
You be issues don't include Bonnie issues
No, I got you, you know, I got I got my mommy and daddy issues. I'm not telling you any of that stuff though
Religious trauma
Cat Jen when I hope we get a cat girl for next time. That'd be cool. Like a pet play girl
Ooh, a pet play girl would be so good
Because I'll be honest with you
I didn't when I first saw
um
My model I had the same idea as you I didn't know
If I was gonna be a dummy mommy because I'm like, oh, she's wearing shabari. Maybe she's like a rope bunny
Submissive so like I totally get it
I'm like, oh like well, I have a pet play angle and then she'd be like she'd be strong. He's like no
But I'm like, oh, okay
She's like you're dumb. I'm like got you on it. Fuck you
Why do I see a waifu
And beginning of she I don't know what that means you see official cat throw down
Yeah, our dog a dog. Oh like a dog pet play girl. It'd be sick. She'd be your top down. Okay. I can work with that
But um, yeah, I think one of the biggest things that sticks to me, um with uh my interview
With strongy is she was like you were always going to be my sheepsters and I was like
Crop wait cries profusely
Um wolf girl for wolf quest
Uh, I don't someone also asked my mirror I was like boomie leave her alone
Oh
Stop
You hear that?
That's boomie
He doesn't meow. He just
Coo's weird chicken girl that actually be pretty funny. Um
Sounds like babe, this is your sheepster academia
Oh
Yes, Johnny is Johnny's base. Love that woman
How to pat cattle you just pat
But someone that asked like oh if you could be another thing
What would you be like a like animal and I don't honestly want to pick something
Boomi can you chill the fuck out dude? Um
I want to pick so I would pick something that like nobody
Really ever like I like strong is because she's like a cuttlefish. She's not like an octopus
Um, I would probably do some sort of like reptile because it's not a reptile girls
There's like some snakes and there's some dino girls, but I'd like I think there was like one
Crocodile girl. I think that was like a Japanese
Talent and I was like yo, that's so cool
Boomi
I'm gonna create you if you don't behave. You can hear her run by go
Because I shake the water bottle at him. Well, there's a billion axolotls. What are you talking about?
Like coming out as a cook. Yeah, like like uh like when Madara was a cockroach. I was like
Yo, I love bug girls bug girls out. So I'd either be a reptile or a bug girl 100 percent 100 percent
Like I thought that was so cool that she was a cockroach
Um Aunt Eater girl
What type of bug um, I was thinking of like a praying mantis
Like an orchid mantis then I saw that somebody actually had done that. Um
What is that's broken hey
Hey
You galloped by um
I've seen a centipede girl. I'm actually I love bugs
Centipedes are the only bugs that freak me out and not even like
It's like the silver like the house centipedes. I don't like house centipedes
Google it if you don't know how centipedes
Hydra be cool. I've seen there's like a Cerberus one
Um, but I was kind of disappointed that she like didn't have multiple heads
Or something. I would have liked to see that incorporated
Slime girl. I've seen like a couple slime girls. There's there's definitely a couple spider girls
Um
My friend Nori, uh, I think she's just rebranded to an isopod which I'm like hell yeah isopods. There's so many cute isopods
You might have to do like a bug stream where I just talk about isopods or just bugs
Um, I used to have a little bug book and I would go around in my um, boomi. Are you behaving?
Fia is playing with like some toy in the in a blanket and boomi's like mad
Like boomi doesn't like it when the cats play independently like if rain is playing by herself or fias bang by himself
He like has to insert himself and be a part of it. Um
But this is a vtubing industry is you yeah, I don't know why everybody's like
What's it called a ca-ma-ma me me me me me. I can ever pronounce it. But
Yeah, everybody's like an animal person
Um, what I would like to see more of is food based vtubers. I have seen a couple food based vtubers
Um, I think that's funny
Yes
Yeah
It's either like or like a unique mystical creature like I wanted um
But when I was first conceptualizing
my VTuber model, not Shibi, like prior to Shibi.
This was made by Shani herself.
I was birthed from the loins of Shone of Momhe.
But I was thinking about like doing
like Cthulhu Outer Worlds type character,
like Outer Realms, and this would be like
have a Hydra sort of like multiple tentacles, tails,
like really like spooky, freaky,
like I was tempted to do that.
Yeah, like I should go off, see Waffles.
Yeah.
Rest in peace, Waffle and the Toaster, they miss her.
She was a, she was a girl, she was a friend.
Via Girl Girl.
Yeah, like Mecha Girl, that'd be cool.
I don't see, and that's another thing.
A lot of artists don't, and the VTuber stuff,
don't do Mecha unless it's like cybernetic
and it's usually for guys for some reason.
Like I don't see, or like there's some cybernetic girls
or like androids and stuff,
but like I want like a full ass transformer.
Like give me a Voltron.
Give me a pterodactyl.
Honda Accord, Chan.
I offer you an Accord.
Just a Honda Accord.
Chick stick, giant robots, you got that, right?
That's why I like Robotech.
Somebody who's mad, they're like,
you don't like just Macross.
Robotech was like the first super old anime
my dad introduced me to.
It was like Studio Ghibli stuff and then Robotech
and then yeah, just like a bunch of other shit.
Like I watched a lot of anime.
I don't know why, I like blank on all the anime I've watched.
What are you doing?
Do you just want attention?
Hi handsome.
Mail on stream, it's my cat, relax everybody.
He doesn't even have any balls.
What are you doing big man?
Are you trying to seduce me?
Are you trying to get treats and pets?
He's just dragging a toy across the floor.
Have a good night, if you need to go.
I know I've been streaming like for four hours
so like if you guys need to leave, that's totally fine.
I'm also a yapper and talker like strongy.
I don't think I could, I can endurance yap.
I can't endurance game like she does.
Like if she's still playing, hold on, now I want to check.
Is she still playing something?
I bet she is.
Forever be online.
I generally, when I first met her,
I'm like how do you get any work done?
Cause you just play games.
Like how do you have time to record stuff?
She recorded like months and months and months
of stuff in advance.
Oh my gosh, she still is streaming.
She's still streaming as I said,
I love Assassin's Creed Brotherhood.
That was the first one I played.
Was there a streaming too?
Cool.
I was hoping for Ace Combat or Armored Core
but it was just Assassin's Creed.
I officially play Armored Core.
What time are you in Merca's right now?
It's 8 20 p.m. into Merca's Eastern Time.
East Code, represent it.
You just don't want to leave us as a good, yeah, I don't.
Like after, I have to, I'll probably end stream soon
cause I need to go eat dinner.
And I'm going to be sad because I have no one to talk to.
I have been like, I don't know what to do.
I like, I have friends.
I just don't feel like hanging out with them.
I don't feel like, I have to go and get ready
and get dressed and blah, like I have to do that tomorrow.
Like tomorrow, just reminded me, I have to get up
and go to like the store and go buy some alcohol
cause I normally don't even drink
but I just know it'd be funny to do a drunk stream.
Where's my fellow Europeans starting to pass midnight?
Go to bed, go to bed.
I used to stream around like very European friendly times
like 12 a.m. and sometimes 10 a.m.
And the boomy, what are you doing?
He's literally just staring at my window
and just like tweaking out
cause there's probably a bug on it.
Hi handsome, what are you doing?
He has like a cat tree that he sits on
but he sticks his arm over the side.
Like he's a truck driver and it's really funny to see.
I'll probably post a picture of it.
Hit him with a kitty, no he doesn't.
Little, my cats don't answer to, they answer to
my little mousy call.
We dare not see the things only cats can see.
Your longer streams go into the night a bit here
but it's not too bad.
I stream from like 10 a.m. to 8 p.m. before.
Like I don't mind doing super long streams
if I have the time for it.
And then again, I can talk about anything for hours.
As you can see, I've only played two hours of game
and then there's two hours of yapping.
My black cat sits in her cat stand
with her back legs just dangling off.
I love that.
I love it.
Like Fia likes to stick out her legs a lot.
Like she's the most stretchy, floppy-est cat.
When cats like just lay on their back
and like stick their little feeties out and just kick them.
It's great.
69, 420 hours stream went.
Ooh, it is my goal.
I'm gonna say this right now.
I would love to do an actual 24-hour stream.
Like I will sleep on,
I don't know if this YouTube allows sleeping on stream
but like just like have a day.
Like I don't know, like you cook, play games
and maybe I'll do that for my birthday.
And like, but actually do like a 24-hour don't-a-thon.
And then like I'm sleeping
and then I just have like my 3DO.
So you guys can hear me like fart in my sleep and just, yeah.
And I think that would be pretty, pretty fun.
Just to like, or like I sleep with my 3DO
pressed to my chest.
So you guys can hear my heartbeat.
Do I sleep talk?
I don't know.
I know that I snore from like what my parents have told me.
I snore sometimes.
My mom one time said that she freaked out
because I stopped breathing in my sleep.
She was like still awake at night,
like watching her shows and I was sleeping.
And then she heard me snore, my breath get caught
and then just like, I choked but I didn't wake up.
And so she was like, wake up, you're so exciting.
And I was like, what the fuck?
And she's like, I, you were not breathing.
And I'm like, oh.
Time to get a CPAP machine.
Yeah, my dad is sleeping.
I mean, I probably have a doom.
Fucking.
No, it's weird.
It's really weird.
I hate that.
I would not want to sleep like a Darth Vader mask on me.
It's mostly cause like, I just like,
I think it's cause I sleep with my mouth open.
All the little spiders can crawl inside.
Have you already tested if the boob bug
in the way of heartbeat ASMR?
I just push my titties to each side of my body accordingly.
And put it like, I have to like push my titties to like,
I can't tell when I'm touching myself right now.
And I just push my titties to the side
and then I have to like mush my, the 3DO against my chest.
She'd become cyborg.
If I could just cut off my tits, that'd be great.
I hate having tits, man.
I'd rather have a fatter ass.
But yeah, cause it's a boiler alert.
There might be a heartbeat ASMR coming out soon.
So I had to record a lot of heartbeat stuff.
So I am already experienced with that.
I have to like adjust myself,
like a manager manages his, his ball sack.
Now adjust my titty sack.
Chibi, you can only stream 12 hours
and Vaude has gone on YouTube.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
No, I know that.
I know that.
I'll do that.
Does it like,
does it like automatically end
if you stream 12 hours?
Does it just end?
Like it doesn't just like be like,
you're done and just cut you off or.
I got a piss.
I got a pee.
Buh, buh, buh, buh, buh, buh, buh.
Hold on.
Let's see.
I think I might,
might end here cause I do need to eat something.
I'm streaming for four hours.
It looks like Amy is still streaming.
It's funny cause it looks like
because I just started streaming.
Strawny is still streaming.
We are the overlap corporal
cause we all stream for very, very long amount,
amounts of time.
The Vaude doesn't get saved.
That's so weird.
It stops recording the vlog.
Oh, okay.
Yeah.
I'll probably go get something to eat.
Let me send you guys to Azura
cause I see that like she's just streaming.
She just started.
What the fuck?
Oh, I just have major deja vu video details.
Reader X are so weird.
Like why can't I just raid?
Jesus Christ, let me raid.
A place forbidden.
I don't know what that's about.
But yeah, I hope you guys had a good time.
Thank you for letting me out.
I tend to overshare.
So I'm slightly embarrassed right now.
Yeah, have a good night.
I'm trying to think of something insulting to say
cause you know, to be the Dom on YouTube.
I don't know.
Oh my God, did you guys hear?
My cat just hiss at each other.
All right, later.
Give a, give Azura my love.
Bye bye.
You guys still smell stinky.